good evening everybody
um welcome to the district planning
committee meeting held on Thursday the
27th of October 2022 at the offices of
Malden District Council
my name is councilor Kevin Lagan and I'm
the chairman of this committee and I'm
joined this evening by councilor Bruce
huevner who is also the vice chair
members we are streaming this meeting
live as well as recording and by being
present in this meeting you're giving
your consent to being recorded
during each item please put your hand up
to indicate if you wish to speak I'll
then invite you at the appropriate time
and give me time to also notate with the
hands up in the right order please
note the YouTube live stream sound
recording is dependent on the correct
use of microphones therefore can I ask
you when invited to speak remember to
turn off your microphone and turn it off
again when you've finished
please reference a page or a paragraph
when referring to the agenda paper and
keep your contributions as clear and
concise as possible as chairman of this
committee We are following the council's
protocols regarding public participation
and I personally regret that I cannot
allow more public participation on
applications except as detailed in the
protocols that are agreed by this
Council which I feel need to be
Revisited at Council to allow more views
and expansive open dialogue this is my
own View
members per the precedent of this
committee I will sort of spend rule
eight Open brackets three close brackets
that's the requirement to stand while
speaking thank you apologies for absence
Tara could we have the apology for
absence please
actually councilor Flem is actually in
the chamber
oh chairman thank you I I didn't hear
Council of Thompson's name um I called
her I'm not sure she'll be here or not
okay because I call earlier I don't
think she's particularly well at the
moment thank you okay well if she's not
where we we wish her a full recovery
uh Castle herd thank you thank you sorry
did I hear counselor Brian Bill's name
as possibly said Thank you thank you any
other apologies for absence members
I think you can see everybody who's here
members uh we now just recommended the
minutes of the meeting held on the 22nd
of September 2022 found on pages 7 to 17
7 to 16 are approved as a true and
accurate record uh before I move that
motion can I just mention Tara the
councilor Thompson has come to the
chamber
no it's fine thank you uh right back to
the minutes members I do so move do I
have have a second for that motion
councilor Nunn members uh if uh can we
agree these minutes by a cent
agreed thank you members
we move on to item four which is the
disclosure of Interest members to
disclose the existence and nature of any
disclosable pecuniar interests other
registerable interests and
non-registerable interests relating to
items of business on the agenda having
regard to paragraph 9 and appendix B of
the code of conduct for members members
are reminded that you are also required
to disclose any such interests as soon
as they become aware should the need
arise throughout the meeting members
have I got any registerable or
non-registerable procunitive interests
today councilor Fleming thank you to a
registerable as a member of Essex County
Council who are statutory Consultants
thank you thank you
any other members
no excellent we move on to agenda item
five which is a land of Broad Street
Green Malden Maple Road and Langford
Road haybridge in Essex reference 2-2
backslash zero zero five two three slash
resm which is found on pages 17 to 62.
members there was an update issued
earlier on in the day
um we do have a member of the public to
speak on this item
um but just miss Lee we've done the
presentation first yeah yeah okay if we
do the presentation first and I believe
Anna you're going to present this item
thank you
thank you chairman
um it does not really that since the
publication of the members update a
consultation response from the ecology
consultant was received raising an
objection to the proposed development
furthermore a representation has been
received raised in comments relating to
level of contribution of housing
um from the development and five-year
housing land Supply
it should be noted that development that
the development would contribute towards
the five-year housing land Supply
however the number of units delivered
per year is unknown
uh so if I can move on to the
presentation uh the application relates
to the largest of the three sites
allocated for development in the North
haybridge Garden suburb known as STD
North favorite side which was granted
consent for hybrid development on a PL
on 25th October October 2019 under the
terms of application 15 slash double
zero four one nine slash out the current
proposal relates to phase two of the
approved development and in particular
the land that is reserved for the
delivery of residential parcels
10 here 11 and understand that apologies
um I don't know why it does not anyway
the three Parcels are located adjacent
to and to the west of Broad Street Green
Road which is here and north east of uh
heybridge wood
here it should be noted that the
development does not include any land
that is necessary to provide the
Strategic landscaping and infrastructure
elements such as roads
sad features or public open space so
whatever is outside the red line
um
it should be noted that a revised
strategic phasing plan was approved in
January 2020 22 under the terms of
application 21 slash zero five one eight
seven slash DT the map here shows the
area phase uh the agreed phase two area
in red which is this part here and down
there this is 2A and the application
that we are determining tonight relates
to phase two on the North East
um of the of the site and not the area
relating to the local Center which is
down here and it's now known as 2A
um so planning permission is short for
the construction of 262 residential
units with Associated access parking
servicing and Landscaping
this is the master plan
the development would involve would
involve the provision of 79 affordable
units as shown on this plan green is for
sale rent and orange are the third
ownership
the development would comply with the
densities
and parameter plan as approved under the
outline permission
as well as the building hides the
development would be primarily two-story
in height with
um some three-story elements in the
apartment blocks where I have my cursor
there will be four two and a half story
uh dwellings on that area here and there
are also some Bungalows proposed in
yellow on that plan
this is the landscape plan
materials to be used on the side would
be primarily red and cream brick and
weatherboarding and Slade and Clay roof
tiles
uh this is a parking strategy all of the
garages and parking Bays would comply
with the minimum standards as set out
within the vehicle parking standards SPD
this plan shows the
um food paths and cycle connections with
the rest of the network within the site
The Refuge refuse collection plan uh
card charging strategy plan all
dwellings would benefit from one vehicle
electric charging point for for electric
vehicles
um the boundary treatment
uh following consultation with the
countries the the
conservation officer it's been agreed
that the houses along the northern part
of parcels 10 and 12 and n11 would have
a different type and configuration of
windows so they are more traditional and
respects they listed buildings within a
popular popular growth form to the north
uh this plant shows the different
dwelling types as you can see there are
several dwelling types proposed 24 plus
three apartment blocks
these are some streets in elevations
um I'll give you some examples this
elevation down here is along the
southern part of parcel 11.
uh here again the one down here is along
the elevation along haybridge wood as
you can see this is the apartment this
is the apartment block and it drops down
from the three-story to two stories
um these are some streets in elevations
from within uh Paracel 12. oops sorry
um this elevation is across the northern
part of parcel 12. it shows all the
three apartment blocks and the building
hierarchy which drops down to two-story
houses
more Street Scenes from within uh parcel
12 and parcel 10. this is a selection of
um
of the dwellings proposed and the
apartment blocks this apartment the
plans of apartment block one
and the elevations
um the plans for apartment block 2 and
the elevations
this is the largest of the three
apartment blocks
and the elevations
this is a one bedroom
Bungalow this is an affordable this is a
pair of affordable
um semi-detached Bungalows all of the
Bungalows within the sides are
affordable this is an example of a
two-story Market dwelling
another one
a two-bedroom two-story affordable unit
these are all examples there are more
than what I have included into the
presentation
this is a three bedroom affordable
dwelling
uh this is a three-bedroom Market
again another three bedroom Market these
actually
um shows the different window
configuration along the properties along
the northern boundary of the site
um a four bedroom
another full bedroom
this is a
the design and appearance and scale of
the double garages and these are some
visuals
um this is from the view from heybridge
bird
this is from the brought to the green
roundabout this is the largest of the
three blocks
this is a view along the northern
boundary you can see the different
window type
and this is a view from within the spine
Road looking towards the North Parcel
11.
and some photographs of the site
view from Broad Street Crane and down
here is S2 F site part of the allocated
sides again more views from Broad Street
Green this is haybridge wood this is the
application site
again this is the application side
and the properties opposite uh the
application side along bronze Broad
Street Green Road
um so the principle of development of
this site has been accepted
as the site forms part of the north
Harvard's Garden suburb so today's
excite reference s2d the details of the
residential element of phase two of the
development are considered to a code
with the north hybrids Garden strategic
master plan framework the north habed
strategic design codes the approved
parameter plants and the planning
permission the outline planning
permission consideration has been given
to the call to the co-location of the
commercial early years facility within
the local Center and not within this
residential phase two and it is
considered that is acceptable
uh overall it is considered the layout
Mass height form design appearance and
Landscaping of the development would be
acceptable and it would be a good
representation of the character areas
that are aimed for this section and
would be a good end of the north hybrids
Garden suburb it is also considered that
the proposal would provide a level of
affordable housing that complies with
the approved outline permission the
housing mix would also be in accordance
with condition 37 as a of the approved
outline permission The Proposal as a
whole as a whole would provide an
acceptable quality of life for the
existing and future residents and the
level of parking that Accords with a
vehicle parking standards SPD
uh no objection is raised in relation to
the impact of the development on highway
safety or the highway Network the impact
on existing vegetation would be
acceptable and the development would
provide would deliver net by diversity
gain
and on that basis they just received
from our supplication phase two
is considered acceptable and therefore
is recommended for approval subject to
the conditions from Pages 56 to 61 of
the agenda and conditions 1 and 17 as
corrected within the members update
that's uh very very kind thank you uh
members will just inform you have one
public participant that's Mr Jamie
McArthur from belway homes uh speaking
as the applicant so good evening if you
just want to try and come to find a
microphone
um Council amazes kindly indicated there
it is
foreign
I'm sure you know that we've got a big
timer on the on the screen in front of
her
um you get two minutes from the time to
uh and you start you're speaking um
until the timer clears or if you finish
an internment for that as soon as you
start speaking Mr McArthur we'll start
can you hear me okay yep yep excellent
okay
good evening members my name is Jamie
mccarth I'm the regional planning
director for belway homes thank you for
the opportunity to address the planning
committee as there are no objective
speaking against application I will be
brief
belway is one of a small number of
five-star house builders in the UK we
have a proven track record of delivering
high quality design-led schemes across
Essex we have acquired these Parcels
from Countryside and are seek and
deliver 262 new homes including 79
affordable which will form phase two of
the widen Gardens of a master plan
having two house bidders on site at the
same time will increase delivery of new
homes in the early phase of development
and assist the council's housing Supply
position Countryside will remain
responsible for the delivery of wider
site and all strategic infrastructure
and Landscaping we welcome the officer's
recommendation and support of the
application I'm also pleased to know
that all statutory quantities aren't
supported for the proposals there are no
objections from residents the parish
council had raised concerns about design
and range of Windows from the number of
house types which we have responded to
by incorporating more traditional styles
of registration which is fully supported
by the council's conservation officer
and addresses concerns raised since the
application was submitted we have made
several amendments to the design of the
scheme to address concerns raised this
resulted in loss of five dwellings and
has ensured proposals schemes complies
of all council's required design and
space standards and also approved
parameter plans and character area
requirements
we are committed to delivering high
quality and sustainable scheme necessary
funding and construction team is in
places that works as soon as possible
the application will provide a range of
planning and regeneration benefits
including the real much needed new homes
and Associated direct investment this
brings in turn providing wider economic
benefits in summary the principles
development has been established by the
outline and the applicant the
application is fully compliant with the
requirements of that permission and as
it officers concluded proposals are
acceptable in planning terms and I
therefore encourage members to approve
the application in accordance with
officer's recommendations thank you
members we have a recommendation uh to
approve this application
um do I have a second for that that um
recommendation uh councilor Thompson
thank you councilor Thompson
a second for that
yeah
I proposed it did I propose it did I
really there I go so we'll have a second
it's been a long day okay so uh members
I'll open the floor to the Drake all
right it's councilor Edwards
earning counts
are none
okay councilor Edwards
thank you chairman uh can I start off
with the members update
um in the members update there is a
response from haybridge Parish Council
and I understand that it was late and
can I explain the reason for that the
reason was they were never consulted in
the first place it went to Great
Tottenham Parish Council and when it was
queried by Hades Parish Council why they
haven't got it it was because it's in
great Tottenham
can I ask that in future that
developments such as this
which cross three boundaries actually
because there's Langford involved that
they're all included or at least the
price cancers included so they can
consult because it technically it's in
great Tottenham physically it's in
haybridge and it's part of haybridge
infrastructure or will be so if I could
ask that please but that's the reason
for the delay in the parish council
response
um okay can I I have a few questions so
if I can start on Section 5.5
three seven
sorry I start again
five point five point five one
and you're going to ask me the page
number
no I can't find it myself
43
. it aims to have
um
cycling
or cycleways within the site now I know
what the answer is going to be because
each development or application we get
for a particular part of this
development can we can only discuss the
cycleways within that particular
development the problem is there's no
connectivity to the other phases nor is
there connectivity to habies itself
from Cycles regarding cycleways
5.71
says it's not close to any um
Woodland where it is it's next to an
agent Woodland which is haybridge wood
and my question on this one is
the biodiversity was mentioned but what
biodiversity all geodiversity
gain is from this development so that's
my first question
um
section
5.6.4 I noticed that some of the
buildings will have to have noise
attenuation products built into the
housing
because it's next to the relief Road
so my question on that one is is there
any way that
um
noise attenuation can be built onto the
relief Road facing those houses that
need is extra
building
materials put on because of the noise
um
and that's all I have at the moment
thank you
thank you very much indeed Council
Rivers first of all I think we should
note that cancer is request to make sure
that we get all the parishes informed of
details going forward
um any other questions over to you and
please yeah through tournament yeah that
has already been agreed about the
parises by an email to councilor Edwards
in the past
um
in relation to the cycleways uh if there
were any Highway improvements including
how cycle away links outside the side
that should have been part of the
outline permission that wasn't so what
we can secure is whatever is within the
site and we can secure a cycle uh
Psychopaths within the site
in relation to uh net biodiversity gain
the applicant has submitted an ecology
report that sets out all the ecological
enhancement that includes
which is typical shift boxes b b breaks
all of the typical made by diversity
games also the side in includes
um a landscaping scheme with Native
species
um
native I mean trees and other shrubs so
this is all this all adds to the Ned by
diversity gain
uh the
the last question was
um
sorry
5.6.4
5.6.4 uh noise yeah
um if there if there are any if there is
any need for a additional uh or
different type of materials or different
configuration of Windows the applicant
would have to submit
um a variation of condition application
to vary the design if any noise
attenuation measures would require a
different design of the houses from what
is being assessed tonight
can I come back chairman I was asking if
it's possible to put some sort of noise
attenuation along the relief Road facing
those houses
through your term and the main
attenuation rip is the the noise band
which is proposed
along here
this is the attenuation band this is the
main noise attenuation for the side but
this is outside this application because
this is part of the landscape
infrastructure which was determined in
the past and
can I come back chairman then why do we
have to have
a specific building materials put in
those houses because of the noise
theater chairman um as part of the uh
report submitted obviously there's
mitigation proposed to overcome any harm
in relation to noise and disturbance
um obviously as Miss Tash chocolate said
the application for the road's already
been granted and there is a level of
mitigation in that
um the as explained in the office report
the level of
mitigation required is in accordance
with the building rigs uh requirements
it's not a particularly high standard
it's not a unbelievably onerous level
and it won't have any impact on future
occupiers residential day-to-day living
it's not requiring Windows to be sealed
or you know box type development so
um it's not considered that this is some
particularly large or owner's
requirement it's just that there is a
little bit more needed on this and
therefore it's a imposed condition
um the level of requirements even if you
could do it and this would probably be
needed to completely silence the road
would be so much more disproportionate
that it wouldn't be appropriate to
impose a condition on that rather than
on a relatively small number of houses
for only a slightly higher degree of
insulation thank you chairman thank you
thank you chairman can I come up another
question I forgot to ask
um I do notice that everyone every
houses will have a charging point but
bearing in mind we have a climate
emergency is there been any thought on
solar panels thank you
I'm gonna come back
three chairman as I've said multiple
times at committee on this it's not in
our policy the mppf in relation to that
relates to plan making not decision
making it's an additional cost that's
not been assessed as viability part of
our local plan and we do not have a
policy that can require that so the
answer is no thank you chairman thank
you very much indeed uh Council Spencer
thank you chair mad your members of tech
please to page 31 5.1.4
I'm really disappointed that the
commercial early years facility
um is not being delivered in Phase One
and phase two as was outlined in the
parameter plan
this reads like a bunch of excuses as to
why it shouldn't be delivered there and
quite frankly we will never make
residents positive about development
when we don't deliver the infrastructure
we've promised we can't hope for that
and that's a reality I think I'm
passionate about early years provision I
have four children myself so I've got
lots of experience experience of what it
means to have
um that there and also for men and women
but particularly for women the
opportunity to go back to work and what
that means for the local economy and
growth
and
I just wish that we could have pushed a
little bit more for this to be delivered
as it was promised because while the
argument and I did actually approach the
officers earlier about this a couple of
days ago on email to ask about the
timeliness because the reason it was
supposed to be delivered in phase one
and two my understanding from everything
was to do with timeliness of delivery
now
um obviously the section 106 will
trigger the point at which
um the commercial facility is available
however if we don't have it built and
that trigger comes it won't be there
will it so um it may well affect the
timeliness of it and I just feel that
this is absolutely not the way we want
to go the Optics on this we look like a
council that's rushing things through
for the sake of our housing land Supply
without worrying about delivering the
facilities and the infrastructure that's
promised and that's my real concern with
this application it's not political
grandstanding as some people might say
I'll always say the same thing about
this
we will never get members to want
development unless we provide the
infrastructure that is Promised with it
thank you thank you Council especially
any comments from officers
yeah through you Turman
um
there is I just wanted to highlight I
appreciate the comment I just wanted to
highlight that the parameter plan did
allow the flexibility of the of of this
early years facility commercial early
years facility to be located not within
one of the residential Parcels the
residential phases one or two and it
could be and also the master plan have
considered that and there is
um this is in paragraph 5.1.4 and there
is this paragraph within the master plan
framework stating that the education
requirements includes two early years
facility it is
um proposed that at least one of the
early years facility would be
accommodated within the local Center but
it says that the co-location is designed
to encourage activity of the local
Center and it says that
um the the second facility could be
accommodated within the local Center as
well as the the effectively both both of
the early years facility could be
located within the local Center and so
these it's not it's and again and again
following on within the report we have
uh considered that flexibility but also
we have sold justification from the
applicant so that we make sure that the
location of it not within the
residential parcel too but within the
local Center would not uh would not
impact on the other facilities and
services within the local Center
um so it's not that we've just accepted
is accepted it as it was we saw
justification that it will not impact on
the deliverability in relation to its
trigger as as councilor spencerlay said
earlier
um this is triggered through the section
106 agreement and this is in relation to
the marketing strategy and that has now
been agreed with Essex County Council
education
yeah thank you thank you
um next on the list I've got Council and
none please thank you chairman um look I
know this is a reserve matters
application and that planning permission
was granted albeit on appeal
um in 2019 but there are two areas that
continue to travel me in terms of the
reserve matters the first uh relates to
7.3 on page 55 56
which it won't surprise you to learn
chairs about heritage
popular Grove is an important listed
building and integral to that listed
building is its wider landscape setting
it's not intended to be a place that's
surrounded by and close by modern houses
and I ask at 7.3 for comments from the
console 2
is it really
less than substantial in terms of its
impact on a grade grade A listed
building
um should I make my second Point yeah
baby points and then we'll get the
office okay my second Point
um and this will be well known to people
who drive along Broad Street Green and
uh uh maypole Road or maypole Road and
the new maypole Road uh as it is
um 7.2 page 54 and 5.7
the pressure on that road system both of
those roads is substantial at the moment
262 more houses
what would that really equate to in
terms of the number of cars
and why are we not insisting on a proper
traffic impact assessment before we
proceed with this number of houses
thank you very much yeah
um in relation to the first point uh the
conservation officer has considered that
has considered the impact and found it
to be less than substantial we should
have in mind that the development of uh
1138 dwellings on that side was
previously considered acceptable and
that and it was allocated within our ldp
so the impact from housing on the listed
buildings was considered at that time to
alleviate some of the impact caused by
the design the
um conservation officer suggested that
the fenestration type is different along
the
um along the northern part of the
dwellings and this was incorporated to
the design of those dwellings fronting
onto the listed buildings there is this
substantial distance away these houses
would be highly
um screened by the noise band regardless
of the design in relation to the second
point
the there was a highway impact
assessment submitted as part of the
outline application the impact again the
impact of this amount of houses that
they were considered acceptable within
this allocated site
um were considered at the time so the
volume produced and and the impact and
the capacity of the network was
considered at the time of the outline
permission and and this side was was
within our ldp again to deliver this
amount of housing
so this was this was part of the
consideration of the outline
Commission
thank you chair well I'll have to give
way to The Experts then in terms of the
conservation issue
um but uh in reality uh as I say those
of us that drive along those roads know
what the traffic impact is at the moment
let alone what it would be like with
those additional Vehicles so I thank my
colleague here for a comments and uh I
won't hold this so I'm happy to move on
uh Casa Fleming next please
thank you chair
um Anna can we just turn to page 48
um I just wanted to double check 5.8.1.4
it says that the applicant has advised
that permeable Paving to share driveway
and visitor parking Bays would also be
introduced
as another surface water treatment is
that covered by the I think it's
condition 16 that is I just want to
double check that that's fully nailed
down and and it's not just an optional
extra your advice thank you thank you
through ceremony yes that's correct
condition 16
um about drainage relating to drainage
strategy it does include the perimeter
Paving on those areas yes
speaking thank you very much indeed uh
councilor white next please
thank you Mr chairman
um right uh I'm following on for
councilor spenceley actually
um on page 89 the wording is a bit it
changes its mind every time you read a
different paragraph
um but it does say that an HRA has not
been submitted though I'll say in
another video it says it has been
submitted
um and then it goes on to mention
section 106 for Rams
um they haven't done a section 106 yet
and yet every time we have small
applications for one house come before
Northwest planning they're put down for
refusal because they don't have a
section 106 agreement in writing so why
are we giving all this leeway to the big
developers and the other thing is when
you read a bit further Natural England
hasn't commented yet
um then they go on to page 88
um which is 5.8.6
um Essex Suds has not got back to us yet
if I've read that yeah I mean I think
we're on the wrong application here
ah sorry I do apologize am I on Burnham
oh I've got the wrong ones I'll I'll go
back and get the right one I'll come
back later
we will come back we didn't get the
right away
she wanted to do that yeah thank you see
you chairman I will pick up the Rams
point because it would be the same
irrespective this and I'll be honest I
think I've verbalized this previously
um it's good practice for reports for
this you know recommendations to come to
the members on large schemes before the
section 106 has been undertaken signed
delivered as you know this can take
quite a long time and that is the
planning process that you come forward
with an application with a
recommendation if it's up for approval
it has a list of heads of terms which
are there for members to say and to
agree
well in relation to a refusal if you are
going to be refusing application it's
good practice that you include a reason
for refusal that is as section 106 has
not been assigned it doesn't mean that
they aren't willing to sign a section
106 all it's saying is that one has not
been signed for the same reason that
it's a lot of time and money and expense
so you wouldn't if you're going to be
looking to refuse an application request
the applicant to do this and extend the
period before you could bring it to
committee so that's the reason it's um
it's just the difference between an
application's up for approval and
applications out for refuse they're just
different processes thank you so much
counselor herd next please
and thank you chairman I'd like to speak
about the the noise attenuation that's
been mentioned earlier
um if these
two and a half and three story buildings
are going to be along the northern part
of the relief Road how will that noise
fund
work
yeah through your term and uh the all
the properties along the northern part
which are subject to additional noise
attenuation are two-story buildings none
of them is a two and a half or three
story building
thank you
thank you yeah but they're going to be
higher than the noise button are they
not
through determine it's um the some of
them might be slightly higher from the
attenuation but
that doesn't necessarily mean that they
will be
um impacted
gradedly yeah and that that is the
reason the further attenuation uh
measures are required
to protect the future occupiers
okay so just to confirm that's the
double glazing then is it yeah
thank you very much indeed Council China
please
uh thank you chairman I think the
officer may have just shown the plan
that I was hoping to see which was to do
with
5.3.10 of page 38 but it does talk about
building Heights and it does show passes
10 and 11 so I can assume fossils 10 and
11 please again and show me that um it
does say that all those properties and I
think you've just probably done it by
councilor herds question
um along the village Edge uh character
error will be um to they've got to be
the low Heights two story so can you
just confirm that and show us perhaps
the design
three terminal yes
all the properties along the
um northern boundary this is parcel 10.
this is 11. all the properties along
this part are two-story in height
um the only two and a half stories along
here but that was what was uh considered
acceptable along the spine road to have
some higher buildings okay and then
chairman if I may on another point then
could you then show me regarding I think
it's 5.3.13 parcel 12 the Woodland Edge
um that's not called the rod lineage
again now now the report were talks
about there is a block of flats but it's
considered really that that might form
part of the spine road so could we
perhaps see that Woodland Edge and could
we perhaps be shown the block of flats
and where they are to check of course
that we do consider they are part of or
will be seen in the context of the spine
Road and not as the Woodland age because
I think that makes a difference
yes first retirement
um this is the Woodland Ed of parcel 12.
these there are three Flats obviously
that on that corner there are two here
but uh their principal elevation is
along the spine Road this is the side
elevation and all of these purple color
here this is a two-story uh of two-story
Building height I can bring up the
streets in elevations if you give me one
second yes so here down here this is all
the village ads as you can see this is
the this is part of the block of flats
the three story element is back here on
the spine Road
oh I'm glad you've pointed that one out
because I noticed when your presentation
I've picked up on that and there was
something I thought I'm not sure I like
the design of that too much can can we
see another elevation of that the
elimination you're talking about the
three-story elevation have we got
something that shows what the design of
that is
yes
through your terminal carry on yes this
is the this is the
um
this is the apartment block one which is
the one adjacent to the so that's yeah
this is what you would see from the
Woodland ads from haybridge wood the
two-story element this three-story
element which is that part here this is
uh fronting the spine road so this is
the spine Road elevation
here yeah this here is the Woodland ads
elevation thank you chairman I'm not
sure it's the greatest design but there
we go I suppose the design can be a bit
subjective sometimes as well thank you
thank you very much indeed
um councilor siddle next and I'll come
back to council Fleming after the other
members are spoken thank you
thank you chair uh I I'm also very
disappointed in terms of the way that we
keep sequencing in in terms of these
development and that we build houses
before infrastructure we build houses
before we get schools we build houses
before we have daycare yeah we get this
wrong the councils get this wrong yeah
we need to look at this for the future
in instead of looking at the pressure
for us to build houses we need to ensure
that we're building the right things in
the right place at the right time
my concern is about the apartment
building that's on Broad Street Green
um because there is an apartment
building on Broad Street Green which is
totally out of keeping with the rest of
the Residential Properties in that area
uh so my concern is having houses on the
other side of the road which are a mixed
development a development that has
happened over time and we now have a
whacking great apartment block funding
them on the other side of the road which
I don't really consider acceptable my
other concern as well is why aren't we
having good fenestration on all of this
site why don't we have traditional
fenestration on all these parts we are a
traditional rural area why are we not
having that fenestration on all of these
properties and why isn't the
fenestration on the houses that are on
Broad Street Green as well because again
that is a mixed development mixed houses
of different ages and we are not
blending in these new properties to
those houses
three German
um in relation to the apartment block I
just wanted to point out that along the
spine Road and in other areas
three-story buildings were considered
acceptable and so in terms of heights
it's it's within let me just go up here
so this is the building Heights plan
okay all of it all of it along here
and along there that is within the
building highest parameter Planet it
allows up to three stories in height all
this part on the right hand side and
here yes yes you've got an apartment
yeah this this apartment block this is
all within the area that is allowed to
be up to three stories in height this
this was a parameter planner approved
in terms of the the in keeping with the
rest of that road it does not fit Broad
Street Green it does not fit great totem
so I the the fact that we're having a
three-story building on Broad Street
Creek to me is totally unacceptable and
it should be a two-story building
opposite other properties which are just
houses we are changing the the complete
design and uh character of great totem
by having that property there at three
stories
only one more point but obviously I
understand this is this is the personal
view I just wanted to point out that uh
the properties along Broad Street Green
Road are here
and in between them there is going to be
the uh roundabout and all this land
which is um landscape infrastructure
um so there is quite a lot of distance
between this apartment block and the
properties along the Broad Street Green
Road is not going to be read necessarily
as part of the road
um in relation to the windows it's
um it's not
um the fact that a different style has
been considered acceptable along the
northern part does not necessarily mean
that this is the good design and the
rest is by Design it's just a different
design to reflect more the character of
the listed buildings so
in terms of those properties that again
are fronting onto Broad Street Green why
do we not have traditional fenestration
to those properties
they're not next to the to the listed
buildings they're listed buildings are
up here uh on popular uh Grove Farm
they're no they're not there but then
again if you consider that this is
something that
you would consider uh necessary um I
suppose this is something that a weekend
condition
but if I just interject using I don't
think Council and Crim cancer if I'm
wrong is talking about list of buildings
talking about Street Scene and
fenestration I'm talking about the
character of the great Tottenham Village
this is in great Autumn Broad Street
Green at the moment is a rural road with
a ribbon development the houses opposite
are small scale and our traditional
houses they're not listed but they are
traditional housing they're traditional
windows so therefore I'm saying that we
should condition that the houses that
are fronting Broad Street Green should
have traditional fenestration as well
because that will fit the character I am
very disappointed that that on Broad
Street Green there will be a three-story
apartment block which does not fit the
character of that road
and thank you Council civil and this is
the forum for those devices Reserve
matters application so they're the
things we should be discussing um I'll
just move on because other members who
wish to speak and then I'll come back to
other people who just want to sum up
um Council passenger next please
thank you
um I believe the officer said that if
this development was approved it would
be added to the lack of the five-year
land Supply it would be added to the
five-year land Supply I just wondered
about the build out rates do we have any
idea of build out rate
so that there's been no discussion
between the officers and the developer
in regards to build out rates
thank you chairman I just advise that
the I would say that this build out way
it shouldn't be a material consideration
determination application so that's why
as a DM process we wouldn't be getting
into that discussion whether there might
be seen as benefits but that shouldn't
be a key part of whether you approve a
refuse an application thank you Jimmy
and through your chair thank you and I
do understand that it was just just my
interest I was just interested in that
particular element yeah thank you
Sebastian uh Council bill
thank you chairman I totally concur with
a councilor siddle that that block of uh
Flats up there along the Broad Street
Green is totally out of character with
any other housing along that road
um perhaps we'll stick the poor people
in there they obviously don't need a
view
um I'd like to congratulate the artist
with his artistic Flair on this
presentation
can we have a look at the master plan
please I think was the first slide
now that looks like a garden suburb
doesn't it
can we have a look at the
picture of the whole site with the
allocation of different style houses
oh look all the Green's gone
that is a housing estate in anyone's
language it's not a garden suburb
um I'd also like you to show the um
supposed views from all of this open
space that we're supposed to be getting
um
well all these all these fantasy views
that we're supposed to be having on this
estate
look where's all that space
that's got to be seen from the woods
hasn't it
there's not that much space on there
that isn't that is a house in a state
it's not a garden suburb we had the same
situation happen down Burnham a while
back where we had we were told it was
going to be a garden suburb but it was a
housing estate and it went back remember
it got deferred and we came back and all
of a sudden it actually changed so it
turned more into a garden suburb than an
existing house in the state
and unfortunately I mean that's just one
view if you've got some more there
I mean it looks wonderful doesn't it
but I can't see that that's what we're
going to achieve with this with this
housing estate
bill could be me could be old-fashioned
perhaps I'm not an artist
I think it's been raised in the past in
the committee of a selfish chair and
other chair is that we often have um the
artists I'd really like to see
developers give us the graphics
um with all the cars from Vehicles
parked there and uh on bin day to give
us a true representation uh councilor
Swain please
and thank you chairman just a couple of
points um referring back to the
Point originally made by Council civil
either that was given the impression at
one time that developers or The
Architects make a point of putting these
large blocks at the most prominent point
of the development as a sort of
signature building and it's almost
intentional
um my other point goes back to this
question of early years provisional
which um didn't have to be in phase one
didn't have doesn't have to be in phase
two
um it has it got its own little phase
right at the end and who is responsible
for building that presumably right at
the end of the whole development
yeah thank you three German uh the only
other possible position for it is within
the local Center so it will have to be
delivered within the local Center
that was your question
through your tournament this is phase
two it's part of phase two so it's the
the next phase is as part of the
um phasing plan there was phase two for
the residential element to the north
east and then there is Phase 2A as it's
called but it's been delivered by a
different developer so you won't have to
stay until the end to be delivered thank
you very much indeed Anna Casa Fleming
thank you
thank you chair um Anna can we just turn
to page 61 I just wanted to ask about
informative four can I ask
um the owners of grapnell farm Chase
have they been in correspondence with
you I think I mentioned this before
um I what the dog along there uh one day
a while ago and there seemed to be
overground piping and an awful lot of
surface water flowing off that site I
just I'm interested to learn whether you
have had any
emails from them thank you
I didn't quite cut who from from
um if you look just uh south of the site
is grap Mills Farm Chase
it's it's outside of the boundary of the
whole development
um and when I walked along there there
was a pipe and there was a lot of
surface water coming off the whole site
I'm just interested to learn whether you
had as a planning department received
any communication from them no
I'm not aware of anything like that no
no
thank you very much uh count suspensely
please
yes so going back to Broad ly Green Road
do we have any image looking onto the
um the new build with from from the
houses that are currently there directly
opposite where this three-story building
will be
do we have any images like that at all
we don't do it no so what I will tell
you although there are no objections is
it in the last 24 hours I've been
approached by two residents of Broad
Street Green Road directly on the
roundabout these poor souls have
suffered um last week you might not
might not know about this they had
roadworks all through the night in front
of their houses with hammer drills even
at three o'clock in the morning so
they've already gone through quite a lot
so perhaps they didn't get their
objections in in time and they said to
me please tell us there's not going to
be a block of flats opposite our homes
they've already just got around about
they didn't expect and now they've got
apparently a block of flats
um I think people might be under some if
they don't know Broad Street Green Road
very well
um it's not
um I have to say Anna far you know a
long way away from them that's a very
narrow road it's a narrow and hazardous
road we currently have because of a
previous um planning failure School
primary school children trying to
negotiate along the narrow path for
first thing in the morning I've been
there and watched it and we've had
several near misses lately but that's
just something councilman Edwards and I
deal with on a daily basis so um I I do
object to this idea that it's okay for
us to give up on the residents like this
and not be more insistent on you know
what we have facing the properties that
are already there I mean reading the
wording of the report and it talks about
a more urban setting that is not an
urban setting I have to concur with
councilor siddle there that it's
completely out of character with what's
there there's a lot the other side of
the road right where that is where that
entrance will be
um the houses are
individually designed
um beautiful homes actually
um not listed no but this is really out
of character and there actually are some
Bungalows there as well so there's
nothing three story that's for sure so I
I just wanted to clarify that thank you
no thanks councilor Spencer and members
um I think we've had quite a robust and
an open debate uh Council what yes you
can yeah
and thank you
thank you for Lee furry's comments on
section 106 but I'm still not happy
because we've had signed ones that uh
that Malden Street Council put down for
refusal in our applications
um on 5.7
um on on the sort of thing about nature
um although it's already been approved
um there should be in the planting the
nature Matrix the net gain and I raised
this the last time we had this meeting
um so where is it what is the nature
gain because that's why you do the
replanting not because it looks pretty
um so that's why I want to know is what
are the gains where are they and how
they've been planted
um on the informatives
um it says that the um the flood
features are not already listed
um and they have to be approved for
adoption well why aren't they listed why
don't we know what they are and where
they are so and why haven't they been
ready for adoption that's the first one
um on number three I raised this the
last time around about the water courses
and the um drainage Act
um and there's lots about the consents
which also follows onto part four which
is common law whereas the agreement from
dance stream riparian landowners as this
was raised again on the previous
application
um and we were told this would be uh
resolved
um for this meeting
um before the application went any
further
um because I had objections from
residents that were not going to give a
riparian agreement and for the flooding
so I don't know if they go to the high
court to force it I don't know what the
law is to know how it works
um and then under five which is even
more worrying they mentioned uh an act
or a statement made in 2014 and it says
the final decision regarding the
viability and reasonableness of
Maintenance requirements which is the
most important part of flooding lies
with the local planning Authority it's
not within the scope of the lead lead
flood authority to comment on the
overall viability of a scheme as the
decision is based on a range of issues
which are outside of this authorities
area of expertise so um is nobody going
to decide whether they're um that what
the maintenance is and whether it's
viable or whether it's reasonable
um so I mean
these are real concerns the other thing
is where's the pathways for the Walkers
and the cyclists because I don't see
many paths outside the houses they're
all straight on the road roads thank you
Council White
um
okay
I believe sorry I believe I have already
responded in relation to the net
biodiversity gain
there are a number of uh
again bring shift boxes and V breaks
that they opposed within the actual
houses but also there is a large number
of native trees proposed throughout the
site uh this is the
um
illustrative plan that shows where all
the trees are going to go what type of
landscaping
all of it is is here and within the
submission the ecology submission
theological assessment that they've
submitted the applicant has submitted in
relation to the food paths
again this plan included here shows
all the food paths that are proposed
within the site including a cycle and
food packed fruit with our
along here all the purple ones are two
meter wide foot paths
um and along here is the link the
Foodway
cycleway link through the spine road
going towards the southern part of the
site and the
um
other developed side the other allocated
side as it was approved as part of the
connect connectivity plan uh parameter
plan
um
did you might want to cover the no uh
the the the the rest of the points I
don't think they are material planning
considerations and whatever it is within
the informatives is not restrictive
um or
um it's it's not a condition
okay councilor white you can come back
please
yeah I think he misunderstood my
question
um Natural England you have to submit a
nature Matrix I think since last year
and that tells you I'll go on and find
the actual number if you want me to I'll
and Google it in a minute
um and what I was asking was you can't
just plant the trees you want to
everything you plant from grass to a
Hawthorn has a nature value and that's
how you get the nature gains and that's
all assessed under the nature Matrix and
what I'm concerned about we're talking
about planting one tree here one tree
there and I know from completing these
and going on training courses that you
actually have to use specific
um Greenery and they have to be in
specific groups to get the nature Matrix
benefits so where are they and where's
the Matrix because I don't think these
random trees actually conform with the
nature Matrix as inclined by required by
Natural England
um and um again the riparian right the
landowners that I'm sorry that hasn't
been answered thank you so if you could
show me where that is because I haven't
seen it thank you
um
through chairman
uh the natural angler has not provided
any uh specific comments in relation to
the development
um we have not requested in the past any
Matrix has been submitted
um
as I have already said uh as the first
point in my presentation the ecology
consultant has raised no objection and
to the contrary has considered that
there will be net biodiversity gain
um
that's that's all I can say in relation
to to ecology
um
and you will cancel what does that
answer your question
chairman I was gonna say my understand
is that nature Matrix is guidance and a
toolkit that's been published it isn't
legal requirement to provide that um
there's Miss tashoggloo said we have
used our consultes both Natural England
and hours the Play services Essex County
provide our guidance in relation this
matter never raised an objection in
relation to the points on the
informative as much who said things such
as you know civil legislation and other
legislation is not a material
consideration determination of a plan
application that is why they've been
advised that they should put on his
informatives rather than anything to do
with the condition because its
requirement of the developer future
owners Etc to deal with that under their
own responsibility is not us as dlpa to
take into account other forms of
legislation or any other civil lead or
you know covenants Etc as always you
know members are fully aware of that
thank you chairman thank you Mr Lee uh
Council siddle two please uh thank you
chair uh I wanted the officer could
point out which of the three apartment
blocks is the one that's going by Broad
Street Green
so because there's three isn't it and
I'm trying to work out which of the
three in your PowerPoint presentation
thank you thank you Turman
um
so this is the apartment block uh it's
not actually a long Bruce yeah yeah it's
not actually within Broad Street Green
Road is further away from it
um
this is the apartment block
from this is this is the view here uh
from
let's say grocery Green Road this is
that elevation here so it's in elevation
so it's is it apartment block one two or
three in terms of your presentation it's
apartment block three three okay
this one apologies
so it's which one
so you're so actually the the one that's
the biggest scale
is going on the edge of this development
which is just Madness
absolutely Madness in terms of the
design and the impact on that road and I
find that totally unacceptable that that
we have decided that or the planners
have decided along with the developer
that that is the most appropriate one to
go in that particular location where
it's going to have the most impact on
existing properties I I just think
that's terrible
and and I I yeah as the great Autumn
Ward representative I am appalled that
you are considering doing that and the
developer is considering doing that and
we cannot accept that on on that thing
and no matter what you say it is on
Broad Street Great it may not people may
not access it but it's next to Broad
Street group
thank you Council Seattle very good
points uh to wrap up the uh debate a
councilor bill please thank you Mr Chen
I just wanted to come back on the um
nature
biodiversity metric which is actually
now law under the environment act 2021
according to dot gov dot UK which is
where I am now thank you Mr chem thank
you very much indeed
um Council bills just asked for a final
um point which I'll allow counselor bill
please yeah thank you thank you chairman
I feel just as strongly as councilor
siddle about that just bear with us
the bill because your points will be
valid
yeah right gifts if we could just give
Council yeah food chairman as yeah
was actually speaking now oh sorry what
we do allow Council Bill to speed if
you've got any points I'll come back to
your offices no no thank you no
CastleVille thank you
thank you chairman uh yeah I'll totally
concur with councilor said that that
block of flats is totally the wrong
place and I'd like to propose that we
actually refuse this on the grounds of
um
the layout or the basic structure of the
way it's been the layout of the actual
whole estate
and the fact that you've got that
monstrosity along Broad Street Green
totally out of character with that road
and I mean councilor siddle's right
there's nothing like that anywhere in
that block at all and then you've got
the the um the farm over the back there
but I mean that that needs to be taken
away so basically on the design along
Broad Street Green it needs to be
that that state needs to be moved around
so that that is taken off a Broad Street
Green
so can we refuse it on that or do we
defer it or what my understanding is
that we've actually got a recommendation
to a previously been seconded so we
should do after debating we've got a
second of a refusal well if that fails
then we can put this forward and if
there's a second and then we can find it
Well we haven't learned on the first one
yeah we've actually got an accurate
seconded application seconded approval
recommendation so we can't refuse it we
we're not at this stage we need to go on
the first motion first but I'll just out
of respect to the offices because it'll
cut you down a little bit short and he
was going to come back to the previous
question yeah so thank you thank you my
understanding to speak to my colleague
so I always thought yeah that there was
the requirement to do that at the moment
is not in place and you know so there is
still a toolkit it's available but there
is no legal requirement at this time to
do it thank you champ what about D1
appearance and design I think that that
was a different matter I think we've had
a debate um quite a robust debate
members and I think what we should do
now
um we have a seconded motion to approve
so I need to put that second emotion to
the to the vote so do I have a show of
hands or does anybody want a recorded
Vote or what would members prefer
because
recorded vote please chair is that
seconded please
yeah cancel my second recorded vote did
you get that Tara
okay so I'll leave you in the hands of
Tara so uh we the motion that we're
calling is to approve the recommendation
as is
great
because if you could just indicate uh
foreign against
against
his channel
staying
he's not here tomorrow night thank you
councilor Edwards abstain
for
eign
against
abstain
sorry
all right Council
president
Council Lego
games please sir
abstain
that's amazing
against
thank you councilor morning
not here Tara sorry thank you councilman
against
okay Council Shaughnessy against
[Music]
the schemes
I'm not allowed to vote
I think he has those things
this way
four
councilor Mrs Thompson
four
cancer White
foreign
it's a very good point count suspensely
please against
did you get that Tara yes family story
apologies
that's all right
okay so that motion fails so do I have a
a motion for refusal
em
uh Castle City
yeah on on General in terms of this
development
if it wasn't for the way that this
particular part is designed I would be
voting for this
so what I would ask is that we could
defer this
for the planners to go to the developers
and look at whether we can reduce the
height of this particular block because
I think that that to me is my main
objection I think the rest of it is is
well designed but I think this
particular part of the development is is
having an unnecessary impact on the
local area so my recommendation is that
we defer this for it to come back to
committee with an amended plan
[Music]
okay so I just just seek some advice
from obviously Mr Lee so um with the
feel of that um Simon Blockhouse are
still would that be seconded okay so we
just need to agree the wording so let's
cancel the bill who seconded that so um
Mr Lee could you just assist us dear
chairman says obviously we can't defer
it subject to them bringing definitely
bringing that back because they may say
no so what we can defer members can look
to defer the items subject to further
negotiations obviously we can't say
subject to them let's see coming to a
conclusion that would be well and
obviously uh member's been quite clear
in their concerns you know obviously the
applicants in the room so yeah we can
look to do that obviously there's the
risk of appeal and under termination but
you know we can have that as a motion
thank you
well I think if um if okay Mr Lee says
we can have that as a motion that's
Motion in the wording's been forwarded
has been seconded by councilor Beale
members for that motion
it's a shower hands Tara uh four
probably easy for me to go against and
even anybody against that
anybody abstaining accounts are not
abstain everybody else was for and
our casa fluka sorry Castle through I
didn't see it down there hiding behind
my microphone okay members thank you
very much indeed
right I'll just get my papers together
we now move on to application
um two two zero zero eight eight seven
backslash o u t m land Northwest of two
Malden Road Burnham on Crouch Essex to
be found on pages 63 to 112. we have had
a members update on this
um and I believe Miss Matthews is going
to undertake the presentation and we do
have further public participation on
this matter as well so Miss Matthews
thank you
foreign
attention to there's an update
um that has been circulated and in
addition there's a further letter of
addiction that's been received
um
um which doesn't and the only additional
issues that are raised are or concerns
that are raised as it would Prejudice
the emerging local plan and Elderly
Homes should be spread out and not all
within Burnham and these comments are
noted
um also
um to notice they're by no just been
talking about this biodiversity net gain
assessment has been received and which
concludes that the development has the
potential for over 95
um area
by adversity net gain and over 22 linear
buying but Betty Net game linear are
just to explain are the waterways and
hedgerows things that are in lines and
the area is is the The Wider area
um
so
um officers are also aware that a number
of consultation responses had had not
been received have not been received to
date
um and therefore the positive
recommendation
um is made on the basis that no
unresolvable objections are received
prior to pamper Mission being issued
thank you so this is an application an
outline application
um with all matters of detail reserved
future determination except for layout
that means of X site to extend and
approve retirement community to the
north and east and also to include
affordable additional affordable homes
so it includes the direction of 203
dwellings comprising 143 one two and
three bedroom Bungalows and 6D one two
and three bedroom apartments in
two-story buildings
and this includes the includes the
layout of state road footpath vehicle
parking surface water drainage
infrastructure including swales and
detention basins and the formation of
public open spaces including Greenways
Orchards allotments and the layout of
hard and soft Landscaping
so the site is located within the
countryside Beyond any settlement
boundary burn among cracked supplement
boundaries located around 50 meters to
the south of the application site is at
its closest point to the south and east
the site are a collection of existing
properties printing Malden Road Green
Lane and mangaps Chase panels Brook a
small stream that runs the days into the
Public Public right-of-way forms a
northern and Eastern boundaries of the
sites and you've got tinker's hole which
is a lane along the western boundary
Andy's bandage to the South and West by
a site to be developed as a retirement
community to be known as Burnham Waters
providing homes for residents over 55
years of age to include Healthcare and
loaded facilities amongst other
S phase one and two are identified on
his slide along with the location of
panels Brook which I mentioned earlier
the primary means of access to site will
be from Malden Road and the internal
spine roads approved as part of phases
one and two so we've got main vehicle
access here and you've got
um the spine loads that were approved as
part of phases 102 here and phase three
will be accessed off of those roads and
you've got you'd have one additional
access road that way and then another
one coming land that way and they would
be linked by a
um a footpath um so the road wouldn't be
continuous all the way around
um and there's also an additional
formative wide access to propose onto
Green Lane which is down here
um as an alternative means of access for
emergency vehicles but primarily would
be for pedestrians and cyclists
um to as an alternative means of access
to the site the Bungalows will be in
groups along the outer edge and along
the outer edge of the dwellings proposed
or already approved with two-story
apartments behind
and these apartments will be to the east
of the two-story apartment buildings
approved as part of phase two
um so these are the apartment buildings
here those three there and you've got
the apartment buildings
um of phase two approved in this
location here
foreign
housing mix there'll be a mix of one two
and three bedroom units
there'll be a number of affordable
Bungalows you've got 30 affordable
um Bungalows for affordable rent in the
Southeastern Corner this would be this
area here and 14 number intermediate
tenure to the Northwest portion of the
site over here
and the option of a financial
contribution in the blue in lieu of an
element of the affordable housing is
being offered by the applicant but the
details of their affordable housing will
be agreed as part of the 106 agreement
this plan shows the footpaths and
cycleway links which are in green and
through the site and linking in with
phases one and two and the countryside
Beyond and it also includes a bridal way
um extension to what was already been
approved as part of phase one and two
and that's the purple dotted line there
application includes a landscape
strategy which is an extract from
which shows the um
the green area landscaped area around
the outer edge of the hole of the face
and this is a close-up of the junction
and the new Junction well the new access
proposed
um onto Green Lane
and then we've got a number of
viewpoints
um
so this one is a view from old Heath
Road as existing which is on the top and
um their Viewpoint including phase two
after five years
and then you've got another Viewpoint
from old Heath Road including phase
three after 15 years
and this little um diagram here shows
where the Viewpoint is taken from
and this is a Viewpoint from the
northeast of the site as existing
and this is a view from the Easter site
and including phase two after five years
at the top and including phase three
after 15 years at the bottom
it's an existing view um from tinker's
hole
so in conclusion having assessed the
application and taking into account the
conclusions of the inspector who
determine the appeal Legends phase two
um officers feel the development is
acceptable in principle and overall are
taking into account the substantial
benefits of The Proposal are set out in
a report which would outweigh the limit
harm limited harm the developmental
cause in particular the provision of
specialist housing for the elderly would
weigh heavily in favor of the
development there would also be notable
economic benefits generated
uh and giving significant weight to the
conclusions reached by the inspector as
I've already mentioned it's considered
that these benefits significantly and
demonstrably outweigh the limited harm
the development of cause and whilst
there will be some harm the development
complies with the development plan as a
whole
development is not anticipated to cause
material harm to the immunity of the
occupiers of existing residents or
highway safety or nature conservation
and it's anticipated that the
development is likely to be satisfactory
in terms of flood risk and drainage as
relating to land contamination
archeology could be adequately addressed
through the imposition of conditions and
the provision of adequate levels of car
parking could be made the applicant has
agreed to enter intersection 106
agreement to address matters arising in
relation to off-site Medical provision
Road Junction capacity issues and nature
conservation impacts as well as other
necessary obligations relating to
affordable housing phasing matters
public open space employment and
accessibility
all the conclusions reach in relation to
the current application are called with
those of the inspector who determine the
appeal for phase two and the conclusions
and these conclusions are equally
applicable to phase three proposed so
it's recommended that planning
permission is granted and subject to
um a legal agreement a 6106 agreement
first being entered into and subject to
a number of conditions as detailed in
your report thank you
thank you Miss Matthews in Library
Public participation we've got three
members who wish to speak first of all
uh Miss Joe Coombs hi Joe if you again
just come to the
um
tables find this microphone
again when when you're ready to speak if
you um
yeah okay cancel the major show again as
we said there's we'll just wait for the
timer to come up
it's not not hurry
thank you
okay
can you see that yeah if I take my
glasses off and put them back on the
reading I can that's better even I can
see that now
okay uh Miss Combs have you guys you've
got two minutes from the time you start
speaking thank you thank you
please refuse this application because
it's cumulative impacts now do far
outweigh any benefits the proposal has
been ballooned Beyond Reason with the
developers now pumping it up as much as
they can to concrete over the Crouch
Valley
it's so big that it will now cause
irreparable harm to the character and
the appearance of the area and serious
loss of immunity and I don't believe
there's any real proven need locally in
Burnham for this extra retirement
capacity there seems to be a warning in
the papers referring to the recent
planning Spectra appeal but there are
many distinct reasons for you to draw
different conclusions for this
application it's not identical to phase
one or two
I don't believe there's any proof that
would be accessed for everyday services
for the occupiers local health services
are in Burnham at breaking point and
transport facilities are literally
crumbling
there's absolutely no proof in that uh
in the papers that the site addresses
climate change as stated and for me
personally that appears like a lie
Natural England did say that they that
this will have significant effect on
nature and I believe they said that you
should refuse it until a proper
assessment has been done the three
phases together we so huge that will
cause major traffic during construction
and [ __ ] the roads when complete the
scale of this development has now tipped
the balance into wholly inappropriate it
will destroy the countryside it's
laughing in the face of Wildlife and
climate change doesn't really provide
meaningful economic benefits well to the
Developers
and it's trampling all over the wishes
of local people
thank you thank you very much indeed
Miss Combs appreciate you finishing in
within the time thank you thank you very
much
um a next call councilor Kevin Coles
um Council Coles uh speaking on behalf
of Burnham Town Council
again councilor Coles you probably know
the process once the button you start
speaking the button yeah thanks very
much
foreign
[Music]
I'm here tonight on behalf of Belmont
Crouch Town Council I'm sure you're all
aware that Burnham Crouch Burnham Town
Council and its residents outright
condemns the entire carbuncle
development we haven't have many reasons
against this phase of the development is
outside the Development Area the mass
over development of the site the lack of
amenities in the air including a safe
and suitable footpath into the town
the lack of sporting infrastructure such
as over subscribed over subscribed
schools and Roads that cannot [ __ ]
cannot support the sheer amount of
traffic in and out of Burnham as it is
a couple of things that were picked up
was the uh external constantive report
from Richard Jackson engineering for the
flood risk
um
the report was for the developer only
not for planning
um they State they do not accept any
liability for third party use of the
report why is this document been
accepted by planners and therefore the
flood risk assessment is void
the traffic report by coat or Cote We
Believe should not hold Merit this
vehicle Report was produced by
StreetWise and recorded in May this year
this does not reflect the large increase
of visitors to Burnham in June through
to the end of September councilors I
implore you to do the right thing by a
residence and refuse this application
thank you
thank you very much indeed councilor we
appreciate your your points thank you
and then finally in the participation
scheme we've got Mr Stuart Rowe who's
the agent
good evening Mr own
so I'm sure you're well versed in these
so uh once once you start speaking again
we'll start the countdown thank you good
evening chairman of members I'm Stuart
Rowe I'm a planning consultant I'm
speaking my capacity as agent for the
applicant members will know that Burnham
Waters site well and I'm sure the recent
appeal decision granting permission for
phase two is fresh in members minus two
together with a substantial appeal costs
which the council were ordered to pay
for refusing permission unreasonably I
only raise this because the planning
issues in the Final Phase of the
development which is before you this
evening are essentially identical to the
phase two appeal decision and in my view
the committee could therefore be guided
by the inspectors conclusions in the
Tilted balance when considering the
weight to be attached to cost and
benefits the development will make a
significant contribution towards the
district's acute need for housing and
affordable housing and that should
attract very substantial weight the
provision of specialist affordable
housing for the elderly should also
attract substantial weight and the
development will encourage churning the
existing housing market it will generate
economic benefits and it will result in
a significant a very significant
enhancement to the Ecology of the site
and the evidence is before you for that
and these matters should attract
significant weight as well this is the
weighting that the inspector in the
phase to appeal attached to these issues
and they are the same moderate weight
can also be attached to the section 106
contributions towards Healthcare and
transport there are wider public
benefits to those weighed against this
heavy basket of benefits is the same
minor landscape harm found in the phase
two appeal that's the inspector's
conclusions and the issues that that
landscape harm is from the same Vantage
points the only other adverse outcome is
a loss of fun and habit and they are
both
fairly limited negative consequences in
terms of their weight you have a report
from the chief panning officer before
you this Arise at the same conclusion I
commend that report to you and I hope
that you are able to Grant Planning
Commission this evening thank you
[Music]
thank you very much members we we have
the report we've had the public
participation and we have a
recommendation I'll read the
recommendation for the report the
recommendations to improve subject to
the applicant entering into a legal
agreement pursuant to the section 106 of
the Town and Country planning act 1990
as amended to secure the planning
obligations and subjects the conditions
detail in section eight do I have a
second for that
councilor fluka who's the second thank
you so members now we have a
recommendation on on the table and it's
been seconded I open the debate
yeah
yeah
um Council skins I'm sorry but you can't
debate because of the lack of um
planning to attending the recent
planning training uh surely I'm allowed
to comment
I'm not even allowed to comment that was
that was not made clear to me sorry
Council skins
okay first of all I'd like to go to
councilor Bell who um obviously as a
board member and then I'll ask for
nominations again thank Council Bill
thank you Mr chairman give me everyone
I'm poorly tonight so not at my
sparkling best so please bear with me
um obviously mindful of the inspectors
decision regarding phase two I think
um yes that the applicant has a point
and we have to look at the tilted
balance
I also think that the ejectors have a
point in that this is cumulative
and what we have to look at is what is
the tilting point when does
harm outweigh need
now this is flood zone one but this is
flood plain this whole development is
it's all floodplained most of the Dengue
is flood plain I could say Mr lay
shaking his head
the water has to go somewhere
and indeed when Robert jemrick was
housing Minister he was intending to
review the building regulations on on
building on floodplains unfortunately
that doesn't have didn't happen
large parts of the districts we've seen
the map are going are likely to be
underwater by 2050. the water has to go
somewhere and we don't have Suds for
this we don't have one as yet
we also have to look at the ldp I know
we have a five-year land Supply
situation but they um
lichfields consultants make the point
that large developments often they they
don't begin to deliver until between
three and eight years from conception so
how much does this really uh really
contribute to our lack of five-year land
Supply but our ltp states that elderly
housing should be spread between
haybridge Malden and Burnham currently
we've got it all in Burnham
Additionally the ldp calculated that we
needed for minimum admittedly 400 homes
to be delivered in 50 over the 15 years
in Burnham we've had a thousand
in less than five years
I cannot argue that there is a need for
elderly housing within the district
there clearly is what I would argue
is the type of elderly housing that is
being offered here half a million three
quarters of a million pound properties
with now the service charges and ground
rents aren't made clear by the developer
but I've done a bit of research into
this
and service charges for similar
developments range somewhere between six
thousand and twelve thousand pounds per
annum
so what need is a development of half a
million pound Bungalows with a 12 Grand
a year service charging ground rents on
top of that really fulfilling for our
residents
so I think for me whilst fully taking
into account the inspect the inspector's
decision on phase two I really think
members that we have reached Tipping
Point here thank you thank you councilor
Bill excuse me I'm going to leave
can I just ask
Ed
thank you thank you Council screens
Miss Matthews would you like to make
comment on Council of bells points
um thank you chairman
um
well I think one one point of correction
I think need to mention is that this
site is not flood at risk of flooding
um it's flood zone one which is then
there are there are parts of Burnham on
Crouch obviously that are at high risk
of bedding but
um this one is not one of them there are
some small patches of of
um at risk of flooding along the panels
Brook
um that that they've been um that been
addressed as part of the um the
application and there would be
um
said
um a scheme offsets for the for the
development and the layout does include
a number of attenuation basins and to
make sure that the runoff is maintained
at Greenfield runoff rate so
um if the development wouldn't certainly
not make any any flood risk that may
exist um any worse
um and the the minor third risk that is
there um anyways
um I'm sorry three Mr chairman can I
just come back that wasn't what I said
said what I said was it's the cumulative
effect of building on the ground that it
will soak up the water it's not it's not
I'm not talking about specific although
there is already a flooded area dancing
because Hull that is permanently
underwater
but yeah it's it's a different point
that's the cumulative effect of all this
building on ground that soaks up water
thank you yeah
um the um the applicant um through their
specialist
um reports that they've submitted as a
part of the application demonstrates
that
um the development would not cause any
flooding and would the direct the runoff
rate of the water from the development
will be no greater than it already is
um the developments aren't expected to
improve an existing flood risk situation
um but they are expected to make sure
that they don't make
um make it any worse than it already is
and in this case it's it's very minimal
anyway
um they're using Mr Lee's phrase what um
wipes its own face
um and I'm sure we've had that that
phrase a number of times I was suddenly
I have
um so
um and yeah so this this development is
acceptable from a from a flood risk um
drainage perspective and the more the
further details of that would be come
forward as part of any reserve matters
application
um but in terms of the other points that
were made
um I don't think there's anything I
particularly want to say other than
pretty much all of all the all the
comments made were addressed as part of
the the public inquiry appeal decision
that has come out fairly recently and
they were all
um deemed to be not sufficient to
justify and plan the permission being
refused for the scheme in fact quite
quite the opposite the inspector was
very um decisive on on the conclusions
that she reached and um that there is no
there were no reason for for that to
justify that that development being
refused and this development
is very comparable with with that scheme
and the conclusions that are reached
um as officers view
um are equally applicable to phase three
and there would be nothing material or
change since that appeal decision to
justify a different um decision being
made for example if we now had a
five-year housing land Supply and we
didn't Prime the appeal that might be a
material change that might justify a
different view being reached but nothing
materially has changed in planning terms
since then
um yeah thank you thank you thank you
councilor Bill uh councilor Nunn please
thank you chair
um so 203 more retirement dwellings for
Burnham
um my fundamental question really
um questions the statement made by
councilor Bell
are we actually really convinced that
there's a need and a demand for
203 more properties of this particular
type in this remote location
and the pressure that it places on the
infrastructure medically and in terms of
transport
and really the creation of a a growing
Community distant from the commercial
heart of the town so my question really
is
has there been a proper assessment of
the predicted demand is there objective
evidence that we need that number of
retirement properties additional
retirement properties in that place
thank you yes thank you um to your
chairman they um
the local housing needs assessment and
our specialist housing
um SPD identifies a level of need in the
district
um for this type of this type of
development
um and even with this um additional
phase three that need would not be met
as a district as a whole
um so in terms of the the need for this
type of property
um that's certainly been established and
no
um not wanted to repeat myself too much
but they're the Imperial inspector was
very inclusive on on that
um the Malden and haybridge and Burnham
have been identified as as being the
main
um settlements within the district where
developments of this this scale and size
are are to be directed
um the
yeah so in terms of whether it should go
in in this position
um officers feel that this is the right
approach it would be an um an addition
to what's already been approved rather
than a new Standalone development
somewhere else so if if phase three that
number of houses retirement Bungalows
were going to go into modern haybridge
it wouldn't have the you know talk about
infrastructure so you wouldn't have the
infrastructure that the phase one and
two
um are also to be provided so the the
doctor's surgery and the sports
facilities and the minibus service into
Burton and um all the other
um
facilities and services that that will
be provided as part of the community as
a whole in terms of infrastructure and
transport they're all technical issues
and the documents that have come in with
the application or demonstrate that
um certainly as part of transport and
access that the development would not
cause material harm the Essex County
Council highways have not commented on
the current application but certainly as
part of phase one and two they didn't
raise any issues in terms of that and
the applicant has
um and the only um slight harm that has
been identified is the capacity of a
junction
um on the main road in Burnham and the
developer has offered to pay a sum of
money towards improving that Junction
which
um certainly fire up files phase one and
two address any issues or concerns the
County Council had
um about the capacity of these Highway
infrastructure in the facility site and
again the developer has offered to pay a
financial contribution towards NHS
doctor surgeries in Burnham in the same
way that was secured as part of phases
one and two and in the absence of any
objection from any status consultee
um officers would not be are not
recommending
um that the application is refused for
any issues in relation to infrastructure
or capacity in the local area thank you
oh can I come back yeah I probably
didn't put put my thoughts very clearly
then um my what I'm actually saying in
simple terms is Burnham's taking its
fair share of retirement properties in
in my view
um is this the right place for more
retirement properties
this is over the view that there is no
reason no planning Dependable planning
reasons to
um
for this application to refuse on the
basis on the basis that you're you're
suggesting
um
that that is officer's View and as
officers we do not feel that is a reason
that could be substantiated to an appeal
I can I can appreciate that local
particularly local people and local
members feel that that
um feel the way that you've you've
expressed but from a planning
application point of view a development
assessment point of view
um that there as officers feel there is
no reasons no justifiable reason for
refusal on that on that basis thank you
thank you a very grateful chair just to
be clear I wasn't suggesting refusal I
was raising a question thank you thank
you Council um uh councilor white next
please
thank you Mr chairman I'll compare to
the reasons for the right application
um on um page 88 and which is
5.8.6 it says that the Essex studs has
not got back to us yet
um on page three of the update 3.1.17
um it mentions about it there being
problems with the size of the Garden on
the two-bedroom Bungalows um do they
actually meet the design guide for
Gardens or do they not and does the
whole development meet the design guide
for The Gardens
um because sorry this must be a material
issue
um on
5.6.4.1 if it's County Council have not
commented yet on highways and the
Junctions Miss Matthews mentioned yep
that's a bit like taking your life in
your hands and I wouldn't want any old
people trying to navigate that one
um why what I want to know is why are we
rushing this through when we do not have
responses from the relevant bodies
surely that's um we're not fulfilling
our duties in making sure that the
secretary bodies have responded and that
we're confident that everything meets
the standard it should and the last
thing is
um the two with the layout am I right in
thinking you've got two-story Flats
behind the Bungalows and in which case
what's in front of the Bungalows because
do we have single story Bungalows
sandwiched between higher buildings that
just seems very bizarre I mean I know
we're between a rock and a hard place I
suspect it will go through an appeal but
I don't see why that doesn't mean that
we couldn't um get a better design
um the other
um thing that I wanted to mention is
which has already been brought up in
Miss Matthews on 3.1.7
um it says the majority of the slights
in flood zone one what are the other
flood zones and where are they and are
they two or three
correct
um thank you three chairman
um
dear German
um I think um as part of my introduction
that I did acknowledge that we don't
have responses from sets or Essex County
Council highways and the recommendation
of approval is subject to no adverse
issues being raised by them that can't
be resolved
um
um
they but as based on their comments on
phases one and two officers do not
anticipate that there would be any
unresolvable issues
um and if they were then the application
would be brought back to committee for
further deliberation
um
you mentioned about Garden sizes but I
don't think there was anything on the
update about not for this application if
I might come back it was under page
three of the update and a 3.1.7 I think
it was mentioning the gardens were under
50 square meters
not the time
okay so that so that addresses that is
that question quite simply
um the application isn't being rushed
through it's got to Target determination
date um in November
um this is the first available committee
for the application that could go
through there's a PPA for the
application requiring officers to deal
with application as expediently as
possible
um there are there are outstanding
consultation responses but they they can
be addressed
um subsequently to the committee and and
as I've already said officers are
anticipating there to be any adverse
issues that that couldn't be easily
resolved either through section 106
um uh also one at six or or conditions
um possibly possibly not um in no
probably not nothing in addition to
what's already on your agenda
um the two-story Flats um these are
those three blocks here the two or three
flats and then you've got single story
bungalows in front
um but in front of those would be
um public open space
um all running all the way along the
edge so and the as I said before the
two-story blocks of flats for phase two
are in this position here so they relate
to to that and which seemed a sensible
approach and
um and they're only two-story
um
um
and in terms of where are the other foot
zones
um I would have to look that up but when
I did a search
um they weren't
anywhere anywhere near the site I mean
phases one and two aren't within a flood
risk area and so they're sort of beyond
that beyond the boundaries of the whole
of the retirement village
okay
moving on the council Fleming please
thank you chair
um Catherine thanks for your report if
we turn to page 77
5.3.16.4 and the following paragraph you
um talk about uh you know population
statistics for the district and the fact
it's aging and it's growing so for me
that that's my concern with this
particular development where it is
because my concern is with the Aging
population where is the working age
population to support those residents
because I think about my mum who's 78
she lives in a rural area she needs help
in the house she she can't find people
to help because they're just not there
the working age population is not there
and we we know that and anyone who has a
business in this District knows that we
have severe Staffing shortages so that's
my issue with this development where it
is it's not an accessible location in
terms terms of the rest of the working
age population of the district
are the people to actually service this
development
your comments thank you
okay thank you chairman
um not a planning material planning
situation
um but what I would say is that burner
man crafty is one of the uh the biggest
towns within the district so
um in terms of population and working
age population
um I would have thought there'd be you
know plenty of people in in Burnham who
would be available and that is and in
terms of care packages that is something
the applicant will be providing as or
offering to the residents
um if if they choose to move on to the
site and so that that has been um
thought about and addressed by the
applicants that as I said not not
Material planning consideration so
um thank you
okay thank you cancer filming the
council Swain please
oh yes thank you chairman
um this whole project has been an
internal contradiction right from the
start
um in combining or calling itself a
retirement village and yet including a
significant amount of affordable housing
Retirement Village one would expect to
be self-contained and
um with mobile residents
the acquiring car parking and so on and
uh of limited facilities whereas
affordable housing one would want to see
integrated with a with the community
um and that provisional development
which suddenly then morphed into phase
one which was never mentioned at the
outset
um and phase two and phase three now
that can what should we say ads
compounds the the the issue of
[Music]
um
uh it being becoming a separate
settlement really and yet with
inadequate facilities
um and with a domination if um if it if
it's actually meets these uh uh the aims
um of all being over 55
um
well
um in the affordable housing
um a lot of people over 55 they probably
do need to get access to the central
facilities
um so I think the idea that two
kilometers is walkable or five
kilometers well cyclable for them um is
a bit far-fetched
um
added to which
um this comes back to my points just
mentioned
um if you've got so many elderly people
um
whether in affordable or not or Market
homes
um in the area
um but no doubt a lot of them would be
coming from outside the district anyway
um so the point I think being forcing
what councilor nun was touching on
whether we're talking about the need for
affordable homes from people in the
district
um
um is a
is glossed over because there's no doubt
a lot of the people moving in would be
from outside the district
um and as a consequence of this
development now getting to this sort of
scale you're getting a demographic
problem
um for the whole town and for that that
area of a domination of older people
it's a March upon that it's already
um weighted that way it's this is sort
of actually actively reinforcing that
um and
putting up too many oh it's too
significant proportion of the demand for
affordable homes
to the extent they're generally
affordable for people in the district
um in in one place whereas people really
want affordable homes spread around in
the current is where they have come from
um
the there's another
contradiction
within the planners
um in five three
15 2 or 3 it is where in the same
paragraph they mentioned that
they couldn't support it shouldn't be
supported because of lack of
infrastructure but at the same time it
says with section 106 well that will do
with the instructions seems section 106
just sort of makes all these problems
dissolve
but whether
the section 106 money can actually be
turned into genuine facilities is a
different problem for them the district
and the county interface
um
I I could I ask you just to be a bit
more consent cancer this way because
I've got quite a few other members yeah
thank you well
I would be inclined to vote against
refusing it but in view of the way
previous
um decisions have gone I have no doubt
that it would be lost on appeal
um and I this is a sort of area where we
have we need support from from Whitehall
through the planning inspectors to not
have a total strategic
plan of the community completely written
by developers no thank you councilor
Swain I think there's some questions in
there early on that we're grateful if we
could ask them his nephews please
um
I would say the affordable housing
proposed is for also for the elderly
it's not just generally is affordable
housing so it would in terms of
um integration of the affordable
affordable homes occupiers and they
would be integrated as part of the
community and I pointed out that the
um that they will form part of of the
development and they will be supported
in in the same way or they would have
access to the services facilities in the
same way as the market housing occupiers
um as I said phase one has
um sports centers and shop and
um so it is it is pretty much
self-contained self-sufficient Community
um so there shouldn't be any real need
for the residents of the site to leave
the site but obviously they can if they
wish to and I'm sure they would want to
um so but uh the other thing I was going
to mention was that and the affordable
housing would have priority to Modern
District Council
um that on the housing needs to register
for modern District Council so it
wouldn't
um certainly wouldn't and there would
have priority over people coming in for
on outside the district
um
the other thing I was going to mention
was in terms of numbers of the
population of burning moncratch it was
just 7
720 11 so I'm sure it's a few more than
that now but in terms of the context of
this site in the context of Burnham and
Crouch as a whole then it
it's not that big
um to to put it simply and yes section
106s do make all the issues dissolve
because that's the very purpose of them
is to address the issues or the
shortfalls or development and to make
sure that any issues and harm that the
might cause are are dealt with in an
appropriate way in the same way
conditions are imposed to make a
development acceptable and shouldn't be
imposed um unless they are needed to to
do that
um thank you I think the questions thank
you thank you indeed um I do hope that
the the residents do leave it I'll
always be a bit more like the prisoner
and over not everybody at over 55 is is
written off really
I'd speak to speak to myself and other
members who are physically Fit and Well
which is great counselor herd please
um thank you chair and all my questions
are contained on page 86 and 87.
um I'll go to 87 first of all five seven
two uh first I'd like to say I don't
appreciate the big stick being waived in
the form of the previous
um appeal uh being waived to try and
sway us tonight
I think I take up on councilor Bell's
point the cumulative effect of this does
well affect that and that is reflected
um in 572 because we're talking about
the quality of life for the occupiers of
these residents
uh now it's saying on the second
paragraph
um that the uh that the amenity space is
going to be relaxed as it was in phase
one and two the amenity space available
is going to be relaxed in order I think
that the term is for social inclusion or
are they just squashing them together
so I'm a little bit concerned about that
because if if it is not complying with
the minimum
immunity space and that's the whole
point of having a minimum if it's not on
phase one or two or three then what
we're doing is setting a president
precedent not to have that amenity space
so I'm quite concerned about that and
perhaps we might perhaps the officer
might be able to help me with that the
other thing is across the page
is talking about
uh car parking spaces and it seems to me
that that there is no specific provision
included for car parking spaces for the
Bungalows proposed so presumably whoever
buys a bungalow won't have a car won't
have a visitor if it's saying on here
that there are because it's saying that
there there is one one space per
dwelling but then it seems to contradict
that
um it it talks about the value of two
off-street parking places available uh
now we've already had a Hint by
councilor Durham at a previous meeting
that Essex County Council are looking
into
um off-street parking and maybe uh
limiting that so I think
is this a sustainable uh development I'm
not sure that it is and my final point
is again of course it's out outside of
the boundary of the town and mainly for
older older people do we not I don't
think that there is a path footpath that
actually connects this development to
the town so are we expecting people to
walk in the road
on the B 1010 I think it is isn't it are
we expecting people to walk on the road
to go the one mile and a half into town
thank you Jim thank you
thank you uh yeah thank you chairman
the um
I I'm sorry if you feel that your the
appeal decision has been waived as a
stick but um it is a very very material
planning consideration and it cannot be
ignored
um even if it's if the conclusions
reached were um
work went against what the council
council's wishes were
um in terms of quality of life and and
the relaxation of mini space the
relaxation maybe that was the wrong word
to use but the relaxation was on the
private diminished space
um so each Bungalow will have a small
area of private immunity space but they
will also have an area of communal
immunity space to be shared within their
little their little communities and that
that shared area of my maybe allotments
or um just sitting out area so
and that exactly the same approach that
that was taken in phase two and and
phase one and was was accepted uh by the
council um as being
um appropriate and uh and and it in
terms of setting a precedent it's only a
president setting a precedent if the
same circumstances apply again exactly
the same because the circus is like
um again somewhere else so yes it would
set a precedent if you had a similar
development to this somewhere else in
the district but in terms of General
needs housing
um it wouldn't because it's it's been
supported here on the basis that the
type of housing proposed the chairman
also I would add is that we did accept
it the tolls Beholder person scheme as
well so this is an approach that the
counts was taken not just on this side
to other sites as well that have
provided older people house and so the
planning system is set up for
consistency and it would have to be a
concern if we were to revisit at this
stage thank you
in terms of the
the Bungalows um I apologize if the
report isn't isn't clear but each of the
the Bungalows would have its own private
or street parking
um the flats would have more of a
communal area parking and but in
addition there would also be visitor
parking areas as well
um but it this application is only
outlined so those sort of specific
details would come out as part of them
or be included to part of a reserve
matters application but there is
certainly more than enough space on that
site for um every every one of those
properties to have
um parking parking provision that will
comply with the parking standards
um that have been approved
um in terms of footpath linked to town
um
that that
this is the main access into the sites
and I understand there is a short
section of the road where there isn't a
footpath but that that link has been
secured and required as part of the
phase one development so there as part
of the the improvements to Malden Road
associated with the development there
would be a footpathy so occupiers like
would be able to walk on on a footpath
all the way from this site into the
center of of Burnham without having to
walk on the road and I think that
answers everything thank you because of
her well I just want to come back and
thank you thank you for that but 5.6.3.7
uh in the middle of page 86 no specific
provision is included for car parking
spaces for the Bungalows proposed
that's what it says
food chairman as it then goes on to
States we can acquire this through a
condition it's as it's outlined so we
won't we don't have that level of detail
at the moment so it would be something
that would you know that's required as
part of Reserve matters that's why we
don't have the details rather than
they're not going to actually provide
the car parking requirement thank you
chairman just for points Clarity on that
so what you're saying is if there was a
condition it would be dealt with by the
parking standards supplementary planning
document is that correct
and yes three time in there
um and there's a condition that requires
that the reserve matters application
includes parking provision to Accord
with the um adopted parking standards
but even if there wasn't a condition
that would be the expectation anyway
um for any assessment of any detailed
scheme for the site
thank you yeah that's a valid point
because we've been in the chamber before
when we've raised something later
further on as the planning the process
of guys and we said we it's too late to
raise that we should erase that
previously says very good points uh
councilor siddle please
uh thank you chair
um yeah I'm sort of backing up what
council heard has just said uh on 5.7 on
page uh 87. and yeah we are real we in
the previous phases and we have a
relaxed this density idea and the
private space now there's a clue in
terms of what this application is it's
an outline application so we're giving
an outline development so surely if we
as members are not happy with this
outline then we can Define what we want
that outline to be yes there's a
precedent in terms of those previous
phases and I can understand the need for
this and I understand the need in the
district for elderly residents the the
last statement which just strikes me
with horror in terms of the report it is
anticipated there's an adequate quality
of life for the occupies of this
proposed resiductions could be provided
could be provided so we're creating this
this awful thing that people could have
a nice here life here but maybe not yeah
and that's the that's the thing about
this whole thing and it's about the
concern that that members had previously
where we probably didn't have a say in
this but now we do have a say in this
because this is coming to us now at this
particular time and the density why are
we relaxing the density yeah why are we
doing that there's no good planning
reason when we have these you know mold
design guide advises a suitable Garden
size we're not doing this on this
particular development yes we did it on
phase one or two because it mean to stay
on phase three yeah surely we can say
actually we'd like a little bit more
space for these these residents we'd
like bigger Gardens and less houses
yeah and that would then release some of
the pressure in terms of the roads and
things like because there wouldn't be as
many dwellings on this site
thank you Council the chairman the
clarity this properties of a Dixie low
density it's not that we're relaxing the
density requirements it's the Garden
area so if you look at the level of uh
density on the site you can actually see
this actually lower than was a phase two
and phase one and which were much lower
densities than we've acquired in the
garden suburbs as uh Ms Matthews
explained what the relaxation we have
done through the schemes was about the
level of private immunity space but
these sites also then cover and provide
a level of shared immunity space and
allows for interaction in the meeting
space which normally are not provided on
scheme so we've allowed for more of a
communal feel because that sort of like
some guidance has been found found and
providing so that's fine but if members
do feel that there was a strong belief
that this scheme could only be
acceptable if they were provided with
private Garden space with amenity a
condition could be imposed on that it
would be unusual to take into account
the previous decision by The Authority
you know the authority has found this
because we've discussed this at
committees previously to Bixby
acceptable and approach so it'd be
unusual to come to a different
conclusion on a phase three without any
evidence of why it's been unacceptable
in Phase One or phase two but if members
have considered that a condition that
required uh private immunity space in
accordance with the SPD that could be
imposed because it's not saying there
isn't necessarily the capacity to
provide that it's just that how we've
accepted the delivery it's been through
a relatively small private mini space
and then a larger communal shared space
which obviously you wouldn't find in the
traditional housing provision so um
that's all I would say so because it is
outline so there is that flexibility but
you know it would be an unusual decision
to go for as a council to change that
thank you chairman
and I appreciate all that and I think
the majority of members in this room
were not here when we did the outline
for phases one and two so so that's
that's the crucial thing we are now here
we can you know we can make surely make
that decision or to make that choice
about how we use how would these spaces
use I I can I can understand that that
yeah that you yeah that that saying oh
yeah and they've got communal space I
know from when my grandparents retired
and moved to their Bungalow they wanted
a private Garden they didn't want the
communal space where Fred bloggers is
annoying them because they're sharp they
can't got a fence yeah and they're
coming in and they're and they're
nosying yeah people want private space
Oh people always want private space and
the fact that we are not we are somehow
to me saying that old residents can't
have private space
that that to me probably in term of my
life would when I want the most private
space when I've retired and I want some
peace and quiet I want to be honor and I
don't want to be annoyed by other people
I'm a bit like that already
um but but in terms of that I I think
that's that's important that we yeah so
if there is an opportunity to yeah in
terms of my view making this a better
making it yeah the the quality of life
that to be something that is provided
that is good then I think we should look
at that thank you Council appeals
thank you chairman yes sorry and see
there was a point Sorry Jim to come back
I did just want to make in relation to
count siddle's earlier point which I
overlooked is
that sort of wording is what you'll only
ever get from a office Report with
myself you know there's always going to
be a level of objectivity what someone
considers is one man's mates and other
man's poison so please don't take
offense to statements like that that
isn't us saying that it we're worried it
will be a poor sense of a poor quality
of Housing and that that is just well
I'm head of planning you'll get reports
that are worded like that six months
time you might have very different
reports but at the moment yeah but at
the moment please don't take any of
these statements everyone's been it's
not a thing it's just that you know
that's just how I ensure that our
reports are written so please take it as
a positive not as a negative when
they're worded like that thank you
chairman thank you Council the bill
so you were hoping I was going to forget
all the questions right uh in the first
place I can't believe no one's mentioned
there's a railway line going up there on
the northeast side from mangap's Farm or
popular tourist attraction just happened
to have steam trains what are we trying
to do take them back to their youth
uh I think the reason we probably
haven't got the space that councilor Sid
was on about because we're probably
going to end up doing a higher on
mobility scooters
probably had enough to get into town
but at the end of the day phase one and
two should never have gone ahead in the
first place you know that was standard
inspector but I should say that's
history but there's one obvious thing
that comes to mind
I'm right in assuming that they've all
got to be over 55 to live there
yeah
so why would you build a retirement
village whatever you want to call that
the furthest place you could from any
hospitals
there's not many of them going to get
pregnant so we ain't got to worry about
Saint Peters
and um if you're going to have a heart
attack a stroke or anything else you're
probably an hour and a quarter minimum
from Broomfield Hospital
you know that that neat it's just
totally the wrong area
and it's out it's out of the actual
boundary of the town
I mean I don't know who comes up with
these ideas
you know they're on Planet Soccer you
gotta be
and as Lloyd Grossman would say would
you want to live in a house like this
no
not by the side of a railway line that's
puffing out Steam
and waking me up in the afternoon siesta
thank you Council Bill
thank you Shaman obviously um and partly
in response to cancer to doll's comment
that the people who I'll be living here
will choose whether they want to live
here or not so there will be no they
will choose whether they want a big
private Garden or if they don't want a
big private Garden they won't they won't
move here and um if if people are
worried that they might be disturbed by
mangaps Railway Museum there or the
operation of the steam engines then then
maybe they'll think twice before moving
on to the site but um environmental
health haven't raised that as a as a
potential conflict or issue so and they
are quite a long way away
um
um
this is uh the red wine museum here
isn't it and the and the Bungalows are
are um
quite a distance away
um and in terms of why build a
retirement varies so far from hospitals
um phase one no was approved on the
basis that it was the same distance away
from hospitals and said the same issues
um would have would have been applicable
as part of phase one as as much as phase
three
um there would there is also to be a
medical center on site and there would
also be
um
people around to to help
um residents um to deal with any
emergencies that might arise which
wouldn't be the case if they were
potentially not in the case the case if
they were in a in a in The Wider wider
community so there is some Temple Vision
on site to help with emergency
situations like that
um yes it is uh
a fair drive to Broomfield hospital but
it's also a fair drive to Birmingham
Hospital from quite a wide area of Essex
which is served by Broomfield hospital
um and this is no worse than phase one
which is and phase two which has already
been being approved without that issue
being
um maybe not not the issue wasn't raised
but it wasn't an issue which stopped the
development um being approved thank you
so I'll take it either you or me are
actually thinking about moving in there
I mean are there any medical facilities
at all on that site
what is it a few doctors if they can get
any
chairman there is um phase one
um includes a medical center
um which will they will have
um doctors that the proposal is that
there will be a medical center with
doctors
um
um to uh available for the residents to
use if if they wish yeah thank you very
much cancel the Channel please
um
well thank you very much chairman as the
officers confirmed there is a medical
center can can she just say if that's
NHS run they were private I thought it
was private and the residents could use
if they so wish but I think it will be a
payable charge
um early on in the report chairman and
do forgive me I've lost the place but
officers have it says officers Yet To
Carry Out screening opinion for the
development and so I'd like some
expansion on that as to why and is it to
do with the environmental impact
assessment also I'm having trouble I
think under
5.3.11
recalling a paragraphs quoted about
Villages now I couldn't quite see I saw
that paragraph to be something that
applies to our Villages our small
villages not necessarily the time it
really so I just like um perhaps an
explanation as to why that's included in
the report because that confused me
somewhat uh councilor white actually
picked up and councilor heard has many
of the points I was going to and now my
computer's decided to go off of a have
an appointment would you give me a
minute Jim I do apologize I don't know
why this decides to go out after now all
this time
just when I need to quote something to
apologize members yes um it's going back
to the point
um no response from Essex highways but I
notice under highway safety and access
and I'm going to quote from
5.6.41 it says EC highways have not
commented on the current proposal but
did not raise concerns in responses to
phases one or two subject to requests
secured either through 106 agreements
there's no reason to expect that a
different response would be achieved in
received in relation to phase three now
proposed well I think that seems to home
in on the access in terms of the
junction with Malden Road but there are
in fact another what 200 Properties or
something so that to me is a number of
possible cars although you know we're
hearing they're not going to be using
cars a lot they're going to be on
electric bikes and a community bus or
something so I'm just a bit concerned
that we haven't got a response from
Essex highways because they're I know
what's very important to them and it
certainly came out of our examination
public of rldp about capacity on on the
road there so I just asked that point um
chairman as well 5.6
um I'm going to move on I'll forget the
other bit I want to kind of scroll down
now the system's failed
then if I may chairman if I may go to
Fire and again Council where I actually
rate these points under 5.8.3 which is
to do with the flood risk and drainage
it says a far and catchment assessment
have been submitted the far only
identifies potential surface water
drainage and then 5.8.4 talks about as a
result it will be important to ensure
that surface water within the site is
dealt with appropriately to ensure there
is no unacceptable risk of flooding from
surface water and yet we've got no Suds
response and we've got no environment
environment agency response which
concerned me so I just raised those as
two matters going back to the roadway
there is an access the officer mentioned
and she said that was for emergency
vehicles
and pedestrians and cyclists but we
haven't got a response from highways
about that now to me when you have
emergency vehicle accesses in unison
with pedestrian and cycling facilities
that to me immediately brings up in my
mind but I'm not a highway professional
I'm thinking of conflict they're very
much chairman and I do think I heard the
officer say
um and also can the officer tell me was
any attempt made to get any response
from Essex County Council and from
highways any attempt to get anything
from Essex County Council Suds any
attempt to get any response from
environment agency and any response
indeed to get response from our own
internal strategy team and indeed our
own tree consultant which showed that
profoundly on this report chairman we've
had no response and this has been raised
by members before about when we are go
as an authority the local planning
authority to internal operations within
our Council we think there should be
responses forthcoming so perhaps it
might be helped to have an explanation
why we didn't get a response and I would
have thought bearing in mind teams we
could have perhaps got in contact with
them and asked them why
so I think that's largely it chairman
about the points I want to raise I'm not
trying to be difficult
it's just that lack of responses
concerns me and can the officer confirm
I heard right I think the officer said
we can do all this by condition 106 but
if someone if there are real concerns
and they can't be sorted out then we
will bring those back to committee or to
me chairman isn't this the point of time
when we should be able to know if
there's any elements that need sorting
out so members might be able to consider
conditions that ought to be applied or
things under the terms of agreement of a
106. I'm not trying to be difficult I'm
just asking and could that not be
considered unreasonable behavior if we
agree something and then find out
there's a couple of matters that we
can't find negotiation outcomes are
satisfactory on I also am hearing now
um and in the within the report it said
this is outline and something we can
apply a condition and this can be
reviewed at Reserve matter stage when it
comes back I have sat in committees
where I have been told
because the outline was agreed we can't
bring it up like you chairman I think
you made that point where we cannot
bring it up at the Reserve at a stage
it's important the reserve matters stage
actually reflects what this Authority
agrees with at the outline planning
stage and then you'll styme it if a
problem comes up so I'm not trying to be
difficult but I'm now a bit confused in
reading elements of the report hearing
no responses and perhaps what the
officer's response was not in any way
criticism of the officer I just need to
understand and have that comprehension
chairman thank you thank you
Catherine thank you chairman
um
the medical center on phase one is
proposed as a private facility
um not NHS
um
the um a screening opinion
um has been requested as part of the
application
um and that would be completed
um prior to any plan permission being
being granted
um the third question you had about
Villages I didn't quite sorry could you
repeat that in in the report show I
think it's
5.3.11 I think it is it's a paragraph I
think the mppf it might be I'm trying to
remember and I took my notes or was it
two and it's talking about paragraph to
do with villages and it seemed to me
that well I couldn't quite understand
why that was contained within the report
when that seemed to reply to like say
our small village is what we might do I
couldn't see the relationship with why
that was quoted in terms of this
particular report so it just confused me
a bit
I think it was 5.311 you mentioned it's
um if I want to bring back to that make
sure I've done the right one because
I've been um
so the um that paragraph is referred to
because the application site is within
the rural area
um and therefore it does have some
um relevance to
um the application
all right I think it's just I think
seeing all that about Villages I
couldn't quite um to promote sustainable
development do rural areas I see that
point housing should be located where it
will enhance or maintain the Vitality of
real communities planning policies
should identify opportunities for
villages to grow and Thrive especially
where this will support local Services
where there are groups of smaller
settlements development in one Village
May Support Services in a village nearby
I think that's the element I wasn't
quite sure why that whole paragraph was
put in unless it was meaning the
retirement village
yeah so um it was included because and
this is a rural area
um and um planning and the second
sentence talks about planning policies
but we're not dealing with planning
policies all the the writing or creation
of planning policies and talking about a
planning application here
um and but the third sentence is is does
have some um relevance because
um it it's talking about
um
new development in the rural area can
support the existing Villages and
existence services within existing
Villages
um and I think that has some relevance
because there is there will be some
custom created in Burnham Crouch and
possibly other um surrounding Villages
as well by the occupiers of the uh
development
um
yes Essex County Council highways
haven't responded
um
and yes actor of development is proposed
and there is an emergency access if if
if Essie's County Council highways do
object to the proposal on the basis of
highway safety concerns then that would
that would be and they can't be resolved
by further one or six agreement or um
the the the layout being being changed
in some way then then yes the
application would come back to committee
because as officers we're more likely to
be recommending refusal than than
approval
um the if I did Identify some level of
flood risk
um and yes the environments haven't
responded but the I think I've talked
about
um surface water drainage and frederisk
um earlier and the reports that that our
company the application demonstrate that
the the runoff rate would be no greater
um there'll be no greater than what
already exists the Greenfield runoff
rate and that is the um the acceptable
standard but again if the environment is
your suds do raise issues um they're
likely to be technical issues
um then they will be dealt with as as
appropriate
um
[Music]
um
all these Consultants have been sent
their their requests for consultation
responses
um they haven't replied yet
um
um but but they they they will and if
um if we're at a point where the
application was was due to be approved
and then these certainly um consultation
quantities like
um those are the strategy consulties and
then this they would be pushed or
pressured to um provide provide their
comments um so the application wouldn't
be approved without knowing what they
what they thought about the application
um
um
I think that's a concerning comment
really that we haven't got all of the
responses from the consequences I know
certainly the environments they do send
regular emails saying we're very sorry
we are really snowed under we can't
respond in our normal statutory period
um so um and I think a lot of
Consultants are are like
um are the same
um and so they're normal
um response rate are are perhaps a bit
slower than than they would like and and
uh we we would like but it it as offices
we felt that that didn't Prejudice the
recommendation or the the assessment of
The Proposal based on the information
that we that was available at the time
thank you yeah I would suggest maybe is
that if members do have a concern in
relationship primarily uh you know is it
the uh
Essex based console tease is that
obviously the recommendation could be
amended to delegate authority to
officers subject to those two
Consultants raising no objection and
then obviously we wouldn't have any
legal accidentally issuing a decision
though it's anything like that just
delay fears it would be this is a
concern that members have we can quite
easily allay that by changing the
recommendation to being subject and
objections by either of those two
consultes on the Assumption as Ms
Matthews has said that it's unlike they
will do based on the fact this is a
third phase and they haven't had issues
easier but that would be a very easy way
to
yeah
deal with that issue I would say to
members if they do have a concern thank
you we'll park that for now because
we've got people to speak at the moment
yep no that's fine absolutely fine thank
you the advice is appreciated Council
Fleming please
uh thank you chair but my uh my points
have already been made thank you
thank you uh that was very quick thank
you councilor Bell again
thank you Mr chairman I wanted to come
back on what councilor siddle said what
seems like eons ago about
um private space and and certainly uh
one of my friends actually had put down
a deposit and and withdrew it as soon as
she found out that she there were no
private Gardens
but let's just remind ourselves why
we're here shall we members we're here
because the phase one was approved
against the local development plan and
against the recommendations of
stakeholders including the NHS and
social Care by the administration at the
time at committee so that is why we're
here and I just think I just think it's
important people know that we are where
we are but that is why thank you thank
you councilor passenger foreign
as far as I'm concerned um this is sort
of my neck of the woods
um and I think one of the points that
we're really missing is the fact that we
are looking at people's lives here and
we have got a settlement which is
outside the development boundary this is
outside of the town it's not connected
it's in between Burnham and Hawthorne
it's in a rural area this is a nut bush
this this is not a village this is a
lunatic asylum we are putting elderly
people out on a limb if you leave
tinker's hole and you try to get to
Burnham you are taking your life in your
hands unless you're in a car
bus service there is none there might be
the dart something or other that goes
through every so often there's no bus
stops there is no way of anybody who's
in that Village
they will never ever be able to service
or use any of the facilities of the of
Burnham on Crouch unless they are in a
car
so all this idea that it's it's easy
reach two kilometers two kilometers is
about 15 minutes to the outskirts of
Burnham Crouch and probably down to 15
minutes in so sustainability is my
question really because although
sustainability has been argued before
and we lost it on a pill we're getting
another two 203 retirement homes in
there and some affordable housing as
well so consequently there is going to
be a weight put on the facilities and
the infrastructure which wasn't
calculated before so just to say that
because we've already built we're just
going to add on more and it has no
consequence it does we don't have the
infrastructure there is no
infrastructure
so again I think sustainability is
something we need to look at and I also
think we need to look at the harm if you
look at the views which we did it is
it's fields and when they say it will
just have minimal harm well you put some
houses and blocks of flats in the
housing estate in the middle of fields I
wouldn't say that was minimal harm I
would say that is considerable harm so
the character of the area is going to be
changed so we we've found ourselves in a
position of having two phases put upon
us which we lost in a pill we actually
lost them in appeal we didn't decide to
have them they went to appear we we
argued not to they went to appeal and
they won but that doesn't mean that we
can't go to appeal again and I think if
you ask the residents where they would
like to spend their money I'm sure they
would say that's what they would like to
do but I also have to think about the
people that we're going to sell these
houses to the elderly 55 retirement well
I'm past 55 I can't retire
so really and truly if we're looking at
55 year olds moving into these houses
these are people that are still at work
we may it may be say 55 is the age of
retirement but you know I should imagine
most people here are 55 plus and they
haven't retired so they need cars and
they need to go to work and all these
sorts of things if we are talking about
elderly people then you need carers my
mother's in the care home 90 of the
carers in the care home are foreign
workers
these people cannot afford to be buying
key worker care homes or key worker
units because they're on minimum wage
they struggle to get carers my mother's
in a care home in dagenham which is a
massive settlement as you all know with
hundreds and thousands of people and
they struggle struggle to get carers so
we are thinking of building
this wonderful Utopia for elderly people
in the middle of the fields
a distance away from any settlement and
we're saying that's sustainable well I
completely and utterly disagree I think
this is this is something that we need
to really think about we have a
responsibility to the people we're
putting into these places and to the
residents as well this is not a good
idea and I think this is something that
we should really make a stand on for
once and actually think to ourselves we
can go to appeal we need to defend it
rigorously and not half-heartedly
foreign
we stand a chance we stand a chance of
doing the right thing for once
thank you yeah just come back see you
chairman I'd like to say I'm very
offended by that statement and I think
all my other offices I think that is
unacceptable to make that statement that
officers have not successfully tried to
defend appeals the fact is a public
inquiry meant that professionally we are
not able to uh represent the council if
we do not have that official opinion
unfortunately no one in the LPA thoughts
defendable and we went out and I spent a
lot of hours trying to find anybody
that's willing to defend that appeal so
I think just and Ms Matthew spent a lot
of time working with that person we
didn't then win the appeal but that was
not because the LPI did not try to
successfully defend that we spent
exceptional amount of hours trying to
work to defend the council's decision
but officers felt it was untenable and
the inspector agreed with that but that
was not because we did not try to defend
it and I am quite offended by that and
I'm sure Mr Frazier is one of the top 10
under 35 barristers in the country would
be quite offended to imply that he
wasn't good enough to do planning up
here so I'm quite offended but I don't
know I can't
defend tonight on and I think that's
really offensive thank you sir can I
come back chair okay
can I just say Mr Lee I never said that
officers didn't defend I said we
need to defend it so I'm not
Council freak have you got something to
say yeah I certainly have on that point
because
um you know I can remember when this
appeal came along and and I think to use
the Expression we I don't think it's
quite correct because I know Mr Lee
struggled really hard to find somebody
to represent the council so how would
you say the word what do you mean by the
word we I'm talking about the council
I'm not talking about maybe if you let
me finish you'll come to where I'm going
to so part of the normal uh exam part of
a public inquiry that deals with an
appeal and I've done it myself
the members are represented at the
appeal so they would go along and give
their views
so they were no they nobody came forward
to do that nobody came forward there we
have Council apparently did well
apparently or apparently not no not
apparently apparently she did again
please
maybe Mr Lee will clarify it but
whatever happened whatever happened no
members went to the appeal and gave uh
evidence uh to back up why they refused
the application so I think maybe we I
accept you mean the planning Authority
which is all of us but I think that if
we are mindful to refuse this
application then we will need two people
to volunteer to go to the appeal so that
there is no question but I think the
officers might want to come back or Mr
Lee Mike yeah I just it's going to raise
the point members it's we've I've had
some comment from the committee clerk
about um extending past 10 30 I feel
that the meeting tonight will possibly
extend past 10 30 and I make no apology
for that as chair because I think it's
an incredibly important debate that we
have
um but just like Mr Mr Lee to come back
on that point and then I'm going to move
on to two more members points of um
points of view and then I'm going to
take it to the vote thank you yep sure
though chairman um I can provide some
clarity and I won't mention any members
names in particularly I don't think it's
necessarily relevant but um a green
paper was taken to members as part of
that it did
suggest that members could attend the
appeal and represent the council at that
meeting no members came forward to do
that
um subsequently a member who wasn't at
that meeting did contact me but that was
the day after the deadline for the
submission of proof is evidence so any
opportunity to attend as a council
witness had expired and as the green
paper that had explained we had a
deadline officers were willing to
proactively reshuffle our agenda to
provide support to provide a proof of
evidence but at the meeting no member
came forward and the one that did
laterally come forward it was after the
deadline so it was too late
unfortunately thank you thank you
chairman Council passenger just last
point just again I just again would just
like to say when I said the word we I
didn't imply any offices in particular I
just meant as the council or us
collectively regardless of what
councilor Fluker says that's when I
meant and I didn't name or say officers
so I do apologize if you are offended
and you took it personally but that
wasn't my intention but I also think
that this is now deflecting away from
from the very thing of of the argument
which is basically do we want this
development do we want a retirement home
in a rural area thank you very much
indeed councilman spenceley and then
Council Philippa I almost feel like I
don't want to make any points now but
but um please forgive me because I'm a
new member and you've probably said this
a million times before but it's just
that it's a it's a question that I I've
seen out there a lot how do we the
condition with regard to it being over
55 year olds I mean would if someone's
on there and they sort of marry someone
younger do they do we tell them they
can't move in or what what I just I just
don't get it so I just wanted a little
bit chairman you know yes the actual the
reason that the condition is 55 is
actually the idea is it because this is
a standard cost planning is that
actually that allows the retired person
to have the younger partner not that a
55 year old will be moving with a
younger partner that's the sort of uh
guide dogs it's left over obviously when
it was traditionally more but retirement
was also a care package obviously it has
moved on slightly but that's the reason
it's 55 rather than retirement age thank
you chairman so there won't be a great
big bowl for car keys or anything no
comment chairman
um councilor flu can find please yeah
thank you chairman I I sort of um you
know I know this is highly controversial
application and I think it's right to
say the last one as well and I think we
all know what happened what happened on
um what happened on appeal and the fact
that the council uh had to pay costs to
record a million quid
um chairman I was rather hoping I've
read the report several times and and I
read the uh the cost decision notice and
appeal decision notices and I've
listened quite carefully tonight to see
if maybe I've missed something that
perhaps we could use to refuse this plan
in application but I can't I can't
actually see anything that you can and
and I've listened very very closely I
mean
whilst it's very controversial with this
you know there's about 10 000 people
live in the vicinity within about three
miles I think there's been 150
objectives you know I've been around
long enough to know when and I know my
friend over here will as well when uh
brick wall close was built there yeah
that's how old we are and I think that
was in the 60s and that was
controversial as well but feminism you
know a lot of this port report talks to
the Tilted balance and it was the Tilted
balance the the planning inspector made
his decision on and he weighed up
everything and when you look at that
really nothing else has changed I mean
councilor Bassinger talks about
sustainability but the report actually
says that the location is sustainable
and I think just by virtue the fact that
you've got the two other
developments already approved there uh
actually gives a massive amount of
weight to that not least of all parts of
this is closer to Burnham I agree with
the comments about out the burn and
bends I'll call them yeah it's it is
quite dangerous but a planning
inspectors looked at that and they've
decided that it's acceptable so that's
not going to change and planning
inspectors unless there are massive
material changes they don't speak
against each other and I think we should
be mindful of that but I think chairman
in on page 84.
I don't think in all the time that I've
been here and I've been involved in a
lot of planning applications through my
work I don't think I've ever read
anything like I've got to keep talking
uh I'm in on page 84 at the bottom of
paragraph
5.4.17 where the officer the officer in
their professional opinion concludes
that overall it's considered that there
are no defensible reasons for different
conclusions to those that the inspector
to be reached in relation to the current
scheme so the officers are guiding us
and saying to us well look you know
there aren't any other reasons that we
can bring forward
to object to this scheme so
I I still don't see how we can object
this I know there's been uh
conversational there's been comments
made about affordable housing off the
top of my head I think there's 61
affordable units we can argue and about
what they mean there's also affordable
rent we can argue about that we can
argue about Gardens but you've got to
understand that this scheme is you know
it's designed to be open plan
and remember that I can remember at the
beginning we had pre-apps and we had all
sorts of different things where we
changed the designs of the Bungalow
which have now become the generic
designs throughout the site and we
accepted
that we would have these open plan
Gardens and and I I to me I think it's a
statement and I think it actually as
much as we all like a space
um I think that it also means that the
community is integrated but I think the
overarching thing is German we are not
making anybody live here it is a choice
if you want to have the garden of Mr and
Mrs siddle senior
um you know you choose a bungalow don't
you and you've got your six foot fence
and everything else but if you're
looking for something else you go to
Advanced so we can't go down that line
it really is a life life choice so
chairman
you know if if Wendy stamp was here
tonight she'd uh and I hope she's
enjoying herself in Warwick but if she
was here tonight she would say to me it
is with a heavy heart and and in many
ways chairman is with a heavy heart but
I think that to protect the local
Authority and to protect everybody
chairman I do think that the proposal or
the recommendation to approve
um it should be amended and tightened up
because what we don't want to do is when
this comes back
um uh as a as a full application a
reserve matters application
um that we're hogtied and I can all
remember the Simplicity of that over
southminster when we wanted to sort out
the connectivity and suddenly realize
we'd done that earlier on and missed the
opportunity so chairman I I think that
whilst the conditions that you you add
weight to your approval in Section 8 are
correct I do think that chairman if
members are minded to approve this that
we should make this type this up
completely and say and I'll be guided by
you Mr Lee and I'll I'll say that you
know we we should be
um it should be subject to highways and
and I think chairman any anything else
that anybody else suggests but I would
propose chairman in the best interests
of this local planning authority to
approve this application thank you
last points from Council the passenger
and last word from Council thank you
chair and thank you Council fluke has
just sold us a life choice I thought
this was a a need I thought this was a
a need of housing that we had to have
because we've got so many elderly people
and so many people that need affordable
housing but this has been sold again as
a Utopia and a life choice and I totally
disagree
thank you Council better finally
councilor heard
um thank you chairman I'm prepared to
second with a heavy heart I'm prepared
to Second counselor uh fluka's proposal
on the condition that those Gardens do
conform with the minimal Amino immunity
space
we all thank you Council we actually
have the recommendation that they're out
which has been seconded for approval
um so the members minded to to look for
a a condition or an amendment on that
I just proposed that we we you know we
we tighten this up and we we mentioned
highways because I think we were Keen to
have something
um I mean officers May well put me right
and say that's covered by Section 8 but
you you know the members want however
uncomfortable they feel about this they
need to be put into the their own
Comfort zones over the approval and we
need to just make sure it's tight I
don't know what you can do about Gardens
I suspect not a lot but
would it would it be applicable in this
case to to actually go to put the
original motion to the vote and if that
fails in to put a second one no you can
amend it at this point in time Sharon
um
I've heard obviously members concerns
about the consultation responses and you
know it wouldn't so uh
sorry so that's nothing you're picking
up but for them sorry um I've heard
members concerns in relation to the
consultation response you know obviously
we have had similar situations before
and it's not unusual approaches so but
for clarity I do think it probably would
be best to alleviate all members
concerns to amend the recommendation to
be to delegate to uh the director of
Service delivery subject to no
objections being received from the
highway Authority uh Natural England no
sorry High Authority Essex County
Council Suds and the environment agency
they're the three statutory I think are
the ones that are missing
and the chairman as well as part of that
yeah it'll be through consultation but
yeah yeah well chairman could I add to
that the ward members because um
uh my
I um I do think if you're going to do it
that way then it should be with the
chairman of the committee definitely
um and the ward members
yeah the consultation of the chairman of
the world members I think will be a fair
act so I think we need we need to make
sure that those parts are covered
okay members so with that Amendment
um I'll put this to the vote so if
people want to record it out or a shower
hands recorded it recorded that was
nominated by councilor Bell and seconded
by councilor passenger I believe thank
you so Tara we're going to take a
recorded vote on this and um a reason
for approval with Amendment please
foreign
based on those points at the list that
Catherine um was Matthew's head
um yeah to make sure we have those
consultations
yeah
yeah with the with the condition about
immunity space be added to that or not
so we probably could
of members which if members wished they
I believe that's the right thing to do
yeah okay the majority of members I can
see a heads of fun
that's okay
we can't vote on that doesn't
remember
you want that condition
space I think by the majority of members
for us to feel now it seems to come
through chairman I think there was a
proposal at the beginning for approval
and that but now this is the amendment
coming forward
so we need to retract that approve for a
moment of approval and put the new
approval with the amendments in so
that's what we've opened on now with the
three amendments and the amenity space
okay and that vote has been requested as
a recorded vote and has been seconded so
Tara could you be kind enough to take
the vote
refuse
against
Chandler chairman I can't vote because I
left the meeting excuse me chairman
after this vote I will leave this
meeting thank you
Edwards
approve
swimming for
thank you cancer franka for
cancer herd four
Council
four
can you cats are lagging against
the Morgan four
Council maze
four
councilor four
that was a shortest thing four
Council
for
eign
[Laughter]
and uh cancer is right with a very heavy
heart for
eign
because we've got a lot of heart
problems in this room this evening thank
you members so that's that's carried as
we move on to the final item on the
agenda which is uh
members just just there's just a bit of
order for Devon there please thank you
just for the benefit of the public we're
just waiting for a changeover of
officers thank you
thanks Tara
Council Chan has left the chamber 22-25
Tower
get it done
instead of very improper
you've got four minutes really
we've got public participation
okay members thank you very much and
thank you and sincerely for your
patience and your contributions we move
on to the last application number which
is agenda items seven which is
2200934 slash VAR which is a whole
Farmland at
583-941-203-977
members just to advise you that we also
have public participation after
um Devin's presentation thank you thank
you chairman this application suits A
variation of condition four which is the
Landscaping condition of planning
permission 22.
uh sorry I've read it wrong two six one
a four which relates to the construction
of a solar farm the application was
approved by the Council on the 8th of
August 2020 following the decisions
Grant plan information by the district
planning committee
so to refresh your memory here's the
location plan so this is the South
morning Garden suburb
um the access road going to the South
and then the site where the solar farm
would be here
the indicative layout so you see the
solar arrays and the inverter is there
this is the approved Landscaping plan
with um hair dry planting to the
around the edges of the Public's
footpaths
so this um shows you the amendments to
the to condition four that have been
proposed so if it is the the additional
text is in bold and the remove text is
striped through in Red so the Amendments
essentially remove the requirements to
ensure that the trees and shops used in
the vegetative vegetative boundary
treatments will grow to a height of 2.5
meters and maintained at that height
from the fifth year of the development
it also removes a requirement to Cease
the use of the site for energy
generation and return it to its former
condition if the boundary Hedges aren't
maintained at the 2.5 meter height
again just a fresher memory
um some photos around the access track
photos of the northern part of the site
again some more photos in the northern
side northern part of the site should I
say the southern part of the site and
the photographs taken from within the
grounds of hazley Hall the adjacentistic
building so respects of the six tests
for planning conditions outline with
them within the mppf officers consider
that the existing condition would not
meet the test of reasonableness there
are factors outside of the applicant's
control which could impact their ability
to grow the vegetation to the specified
Heights and density by the fifth year
and retain them at those Heights for
instance accounts was agricultural
consultant has provided an example and
such as when the vegetation may be
subject to suppression
also the maintenance of the Hedge at
this consistent height would
would be considered to be after keeping
with the character and appearance of the
area and surrounding vegetation
in considering these matters against the
level of harm that would arise from the
failure of the screening and the
requirement to cease to use if the
vegetation should fail it's not
considered that the existing condition
is proportionate and therefore the
condition is considered unreasonable
prize wedding however ensures that the
species are
ensures that species that are capable of
growing to this height would be provided
which would secure a level of screening
on site without imposing requirements
that would be outside of the applicant's
control therefore it's considered that
the revised wording would meet the six
tests of the planning conditions and the
application is therefore recommended for
approval thank you chairman thank you
very much indeed now we have um we may
have a public participation um Mr
Hartley Bond who may be attended by
Microsoft teams Tara is Mr Bond
available
okay yeah so many years if I could just
ask the officer to minimize the screen
so that we can see you can see Mr hardy
Bond on your screen
thanks Mr Heidi Bond
okay can you see the the timer Mr Holly
Bond
I can't but I can assure you
are it's under two minutes okay
no that's okay they said the times are
cracking on but this is important so we
have two minutes to timing starts when
you start speaking
um Mr bonso when you're ready thank you
thank you chairman
um well at first I just want to say
we're we're grateful to your Council for
the approval of our proposal from the
committee back in July
um we noted the requests for members for
additional conditions in relation to
archeology and Landscaping and with no
issues with the additional
archaeological conditions and with
regards to the landscape and request we
understand the sentiment to ensure the
best possible landscaping for the site I
think it's fair to say I I hope we're
all on the same page and that we also
wish to see the best possible
landscaping for the science the only
speaking point is the specific wording
of that condition and as it's written it
just creates a problem for us firstly as
you've heard from your officer even with
the best of intentions it requires us to
do something that is unfortunately
beyond our gift and that is to guarantee
that the hedging will grow to a set
height in a set period of time
and secondly the penalty of not
achieving that is that we would have to
decommission the entire site and
therefore it's very difficult for us to
move ahead with the project due to that
high level of uncertainty and Financial
Risk that the wording introduces
the variation before you attempts to
strike the right balance hopefully
between the desire to see sufficient
screening of the proposal and a scheme
which is deliverable we hope this is an
acceptable compromise to the committee
and we hope that we can continue to
count on your support for the delivery
of clean energy into your area next year
thank you thank you Mr Hartley Bond
thank you for your presentation and the
apologies for for running Soleil so
members we actually have a
recommendation to approve this variation
which is approved subject conditions set
out in section eight do I have a second
for that that's Castle Morgan secretary
thank you members I can now open the
debate foreign
Morgan okay Council fluka thank you yeah
thank you chairman I I mean I'm I'm sure
that members would be aware of the
abergavenny uh um solar Park uh where
there was actually a condition uh
imposed for three meter hedging and
screening uh and it was it was actually
agreed on appeal
um so you know perhaps the soil was much
better there and they could actually go
within the five years which it mentions
and rather ironically they then came
back and asked to reduce 100 meter
section down to 2.5 because it impacted
on The View when leaving the site but
there's also stances solar farm which
was agreed on appeal it's interesting
that these all agreed on appeal an
appeal on the ninth of August August
this year and and there were lots of
conditions in there about
um screening by trees and everything
else and a lot of those I think are
covered by the Lemp and if I'm wrong I'm
sure the officers put me right which is
a landscape an ecological plan so
chairman as long as as long as we can
ensure as long as we can ensure that the
um the screening
um you know does at some time or whether
come to the 2.5 meters
um then I don't really have any
objection to this and I I do notice in
the report somewhere that it said that
it could be subject to enforcement
anyway
um this is always a problem when and and
I think it was actually me that proposed
that we had this screening
um and I think also I think the the uh
the applicant who just spoke actually
phoned me at home and I asked him to
email me but he never did because I'm
sure we could have perhaps exchanged an
email on this and saved a lot of time
but I think that when you know I propose
that and to me it sounded quite a
reasonable uh proposition in as far as
the fact that within five years two and
a half meters yeah which isn't massive
you know we all grow Hedges and they
soon up to two and a half meters but it
was never my intent to say that if it
never if it didn't reach 2.5 you've got
a decommission the whole site that would
be totally ridiculous and I think it
might have been useful if somebody had
spoken to me and said is this really
what you meant and clearly I didn't but
I think we've just got to make sure that
the
um whoever builds this site
um you know extends their best Endeavors
to make sure this does grow to 2.5
meters and I think I'm if I am right the
Lemp controls Legacy so in other words
you know by the time this changes hands
several times before it's built or
perhaps even whilst when it's been built
or at some time we've got to make sure
that there's there's the Legacy
condition in there which is normally in
the limp
um so to make sure that all these
conditions are carried through the 25
years or whatever this is proposed for
and the most critical one of course is
at the end making sure that the finances
available at the end to clear the site
because this is what the plan payment
and I'm sorry to boring you everybody
but it's amazing what you can find out
on 30 minutes in Google and I'm sure
Abba venue is a lovely place and they'll
be delighted when they find out they
were mentioned here tonight but chairman
uh that aside as long as we can deal
with this properly and control it uh
then Gemini propose we agree this
recommendation thank you Council fluka I
think that's more of a statement than
questions there's a counselor
there was some information sharing there
and some views which is fine I don't
expect the officers to come back on that
councilman please
so unless I've misunderstood the
officer's report on what we're being
told is um nature being nature that we
that the issue of height it wouldn't be
an enforceable condition
dude chairman it's not it's not in
forceful issue it's just the extremity
of what was being proposed last time
what we're proposing now is a condition
that we'll hopefully deliver that and
should deliver that well it was the uh
ownlessness of the previous one that is
the issue but as you said nature being
nature we can't be 100 we wouldn't want
an extreme an unreasonable condition
because that's not
making the six test thank you Council
Angela come back on that well um I'm
only in so much as I think the applicant
has been very fair and balanced so far
in terms of the things that we require
and uh I don't have a problem with the
amendments to the wording thank you
thank you very much indeed uh councilor
bill please
come as a shock but I'm actually in
agreement with just changing these few
words no one can determine how fast or
slow the implants are going to grow
depending on weather climate whatever
and I think it's a very practical
suggestion and I
I agree with the officer's
recommendation thank you councilor bill
um councilor Morgan please
yeah I think a chairman I I agree with
my councilor Beale I I take council's
Lucas point about it being
um the um this restricted or has
actually been held an appeal but I would
just say Abigail is in a very wet Wales
and we're in a very hot and dry Essex
and I think to
try and suggest that you actually have
to comply with a 2.5 meter I mean I know
our border list but that sounds very
much like knut trying to control the the
the tides so I I'm certainly in favor of
the larynx thank you again can I just
come back this is going to be monitored
it's just giving away just a moment
thank you yes this is going to be
monitored
as much as possible as in you know
they've got to be shown to be actually
trying to do whatever
the chairman the condition requires
details to be submitted that will show
that it should be achievable yeah thank
you thank you Council Spencer thank you
for your patience no that's fine all I
wanted to say was we must be supporting
applications like this I make no Miss no
um secret of the fact that I'm a huge
climate action supporter so I think that
we must support an application like this
and I think it looks like it could be
managed reasonably so I would just urge
everyone to to consider that thank you
thank you Council Spencer so members we
know we have no other members who wish
to speak so what I'd like to do is put
the recommendation for which has been
seconded so we do this by a show of
hands and set members that's unanimous
um time uh we've moved on to item number
six any other items of urgent business
the chairman decides are Urgent I've got
a couple of hours worth of speech no I
haven't there are none so I members
thank you for your contributions I close
this meeting at 10 38 pm thank you